this is Jocko podcast number 359 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink
good evening Echo good evening
there was a loud burst of gunfire
and Cowie fell to the ground exposed in
the street
he had taken around to his right femur
The Barrage of enemy gunfire continued
to Cascade toward him from multiple
enemy positions kicking up dust and
sending Ricochet and secondary frag of
rock and concrete right at him
Cowie immediately returned fire but was
unable to move quickly to cover because
of the Grievous injury to his leg
within seconds of hitting the ground
Cowie heard a new weapon entered the
chaos
Michael Monsour the automatic weapons
Gunner broke from his covered position
in an adjacent Courtyard into the middle
of the street
in that same moment Michael sent a long
burst of 762 millimeter rounds from his
Mark 48 machine gun into enemy positions
although carrying a heavy load of
equipment Michael deftly moved to where
Cowie lay wounded and bleeding
he stood in front of him and used his
lean frame and armor as a shield to
protect Cowie from incoming enemy fire
this gave the wounded seal a reprieve he
needed to continue to call for backup on
His Radio
Michael's technical Acumen was apparent
as he swiftly engaged and suppressed
enemy positions with his Mark 48
effectively known as the pig
every second and every round mattered
the other seal began to prepare Cowie to
move while Michael engaged enemy
insurgents
let's move the other seal shouted
Michael grabbed cowie's drag handle on
top of his armor and began to pull him
back to the Courtyard while still firing
his mark 48.
Cowie looked up at Michael as he dragged
him across the road but the perspective
was not what he expected
how he felt as if for just a moment he
had left his body below
he looked down upon the scene
as Michael dragged him the snaps and
ricochets of the heavy machine gun of
enemy fire continued to hit the ground
around them Cowie couldn't believe that
not one round had found its intended
target
instantly the light seemed to shift then
Cowie saw them
two large feathered wings wrapped from
behind Michael around the trio as they
moved him out of the street
how we knew in that instant
they were not alone in the fight
then Cowie was looking up at Michael
again
he could feel the pain and hear the
gunfire dust filled the air and the the
sun beat down upon them as they moved
once back behind cover the other seal
began working on his injured teammate
the enemy fire picked up again just as
Michael finished reloading
Michael answered with a heavy volley
into the enemy position
JP and the rest of the squad along with
their Iraqi Partners joined the
firefight minutes later Lieutenant Seth
Stone the officer in charge of Delta
platoon was deep into radio comms
providing situation updates to the chain
of command coordinating with units in
other sectors and facilitating the
movement
of the responding soldiers Marines and
Iraqi Partners into the fight
and that right there is an excerpt
from a book that has just come out which
is entitled defend Us in battle the true
story of ma2 Navy SEAL Medal of Honor
recipient Michael a a Mansour
then the book was written by Michael's
father George Monsour along with rose
Ray who is an author and is also the
wife of a seal
and the book was written by interviewing
friends and family of Michael
many of the members of tasking to
Bruiser shared their stories to paint a
picture of Michael's bravery
his character his scale as a seal
but of course Michael monsor was much
more than just a seal
he was a man of compassion
of humor of love
and of faith
he was the best
and he set an incredible example for all
who knew him
and for anyone
that hears his story and it's an honor
to have
Michael's dad George Monsour here with
us tonight
to share some of this incredible story
with us
George
thanks Richard thanks for joining us
tonight thanks for having me on that's
uh it's an honor to have you down here
[Music]
um I know it's not that far of a drive
but I know it can be a little
challenging sometimes
uh but glad you could make it down
um
I guess before we get I guess we have to
start at this story maybe at the
beginning with a little bit about you
and your background
so you're originally from Wisconsin is
that right
yeah I was born in La Crosse and uh my
family came from uh uh Lebanon
so uh there was that transition so are
you first generation American or are you
second generation no it's like half half
overboard and half so I I was uh you
know it was half of that family there's
like 10 kids uh were born here uh here
and half was born on the other side so
uh yeah so there's a whole kind of a
different world
uh the Middle Eastern world and the
American World so uh yeah there's things
that always a little different
and and so you were how how long did you
stay in Wisconsin for uh not very long
um I I think uh they asked us to leave
like the first year you know they told
us to get out of Wisconsin
went to California and then it was
California and so how old were you when
you ended up in California that's
probably pretty young yeah that's
probably about one and uh that's kind of
well you know where uh the rest of the
family was born I had uh two brothers
and three sisters
uh my dad was uh uh in World War II and
um he had a lot of problems after the
war
and um he couldn't hold down a job and
he ended up just being a gambler so we
had kind of a uh you know I mean we
didn't realize uh it wasn't the best but
uh our family was close and uh my mom
basically was the one that uh kept
everything together
and we didn't realize we were poor until
somebody told me in school
and uh so then as you're growing up
you're growing up in California in like
the 50s and 60s then yeah
that had to be pretty is it like how
does that compare with the movies
well
we would watch these these movies and
our TV shows and you'd have uh Father
Knows bass and all these fathers are
walking around with suits and ties
I look over my dad he's an escape he's
reading the racing floor the only thing
he ever says can is beer me you know
so yeah I would look at the TV and look
at our family not quite the same
uh so you end up I mean you own a school
where'd you where'd you go to high
school I went to uh St John Bosco it's a
boys school
um I was fortunate that I was a pretty
good football player so it was a good
fit
it was uh
it was
um it was pretty tough those priests
these guys served in World War II and
they didn't put up with a lot of
nonsense and it was probably the best
thing for me they made it very clear
what I could do what I couldn't do
and then so you played football yeah and
what was your plan when you graduate
when you graduated I mean nowadays like
everyone has to go to college has to go
to college did you have that plan or
yeah the plan was because it was the
college prep school was to go to college
but it was an all boys school so my plan
was different when I went to college
you had to make up for lost time
I was anybody that wanted to get on the
back of my motorcycle
so uh I basically uh my grades uh
basically said to me you're going to get
drafted so uh I decided to outsmart them
and I joined the Marine Corps
okay
[Music]
awesome yeah yeah you're outsmarted
about that one huh so what year was it
that you joined the Marine Corps uh 68 I
went 68 to 72. so so I mean when you
Vietnam is full-blown in 1968 when you
joined no like you you is it just known
that you're going to Vietnam yeah
um especially in my MOS it wasn't the
MOs I wanted uh I was that guy that was
always trying to stay out of The Fray
You know stay in the middle yeah but
anyway the problem was if your grades
weren't weren't uh good then you you'd
go straight over as a grunt I didn't
want to be a grunt uh so um I kept my
grades up but the thing was every time
you did well in school you got another
school I did well in the test I got
Aviation school and then Aviation school
I did well and I got helicopters
helicopters is not where you want to be
in the Marine Corps
even it's funny even as you say like oh
I went to school for Aviation and like
that sounds that sounds like you know
okay you're gonna go learn this trade
and you're gonna work on aircraft
exactly in Vietnam that's a little bit
different it's a little bit of a
different outcome I got there and I said
hey you know this wasn't the deal you
know when you sign up they said tell you
one thing but you don't always get what
you want and I certainly didn't it was
like this wasn't the Gale and the guy
goes you'll have more schools don't
worry about it the last school I went to
was machine gun 50 cal machine gun
school that was it what was uh what was
the Shaka boot camp like
um actually uh
playing boss uh Bosco football
wasn't uh the boot camp wasn't a big
deal
we had uh we had a coach that carried a
baseball bat Jesus and I remember since
it was a Catholic school he told us why
God gave his heads and that was to
punish the other players
and they had this bat and we had the
cages and he would smack you in the head
with the with the bat just so you
understood what you're supposed to use
your head for and I remember we had a
game I think it was Venice and uh
we were just brutal we weren't brutal on
purposes that's the way we were trained
to head and uh the principal wrote a
letter to the school after you know
after the game just trashy we didn't
cheat or anything uh we played a
straight game but we laid people out
so many car boot camp was perfectly fine
yeah it was fine you know I had a couple
of problems uh
just understanding it because they
really my family served World War uh two
Korean War and uh as you know my sons
all served in the Marine Corps other
than Mike but I didn't get it I was like
uh I thought you'd go in and um you know
you get paid uh I thought at least
minimum wage
in in all the military stuff it just
wasn't used to because my father was
definitely you don't get a lot of uh
discipline from a professional Gambler
so uh it was another world for me the
most discipline got was at uh Saint John
Bosco but I remember on payday you go in
you get a little bit of money to get
your soap and those type of things and
uh so they gave us instructions they
said you go in there you march in there
you make a right turn then a left turn
then you send yourself in front of the
CO's desk he will push a book in front
of you you look down and look at that
pay book and you will say the service or
the the pay is correct sir
and look straight ahead
so I'm thinking okay you know I do it
perfect and I look down
and I say 36 dollars
where's your military buried and uh for
36 dollars
so they it was uh they finally got my
attention and got me squared away I was
surprised that for quite a while
foreign
School you went to was 50 cal school but
they sent you the Hilo school and then
what year did you deploy to Vietnam uh
it was uh
uh let's see I think it was 19 so it was
uh 69
and got back in yeah 69 August 69 I
think it was yeah I think it was August
69. and how was the uh how was the
deployment how did you get over there
did you take a charter aircraft over
there yeah we took a uh I think it was a
Pan Am
that was uh that was just a zoo I mean
the officers were in front and the
snuffys were in the back and uh you
could just see it on those stewardesses
faces which one they wanted to be frank
or the back
it was a long it was a long flight and
it was 16 hours and uh we landed the
only we landed once for fuel in Hawaii
and then they literally wouldn't let us
get off they had the guards out there
I'm thinking they passed the message to
us or what and then we finally got in
and started sorting out uh where we were
going to go and I was really fortunate
in the long run because uh you know how
this works you just your number and
these guys would go here and these guys
will go here and I just skated through
the whole deal I ended up uh in only
going there for just a little bit and
then I was simply
um at Okinawa most of the time
and I started feeling guilty because
um you know my friends were over there
and then when they were coming back
uh some big changes and it really broke
my heart and I God I feel so guilty uh I
was just there for a blank so
um you know how you're in this service
and you just don't understand how
certain things happen you know it's like
um how a close friend uh you know will
go and or the or some of them come back
and they just they just screwed up and
it reminded me of my dad and that's why
I didn't get my dad until I was in the
Marine Corps and I realized I would go
to the hospital at veterans hospital
when he was young had these breakdowns
but I still couldn't get it through my
head what was going on then after I saw
the Vets coming back in Okinawa where
you're getting cleaned up ready to go
realize there's some guys that really
got hit hard mentally and physically too
but mentally is really
something that just doesn't go away what
did your what did your dad do in World
War II was he in the Army was in the
Marine Corps my dad was uh it's actually
a super athlete
um he was a Golden Glove Champion he was
the fleet Naval champion and back then
there was a lot of that's where all the
men were but he was in the Navy and he
was on I don't know what they call him
like uh Pom-Pom guns or something
they're they're on an air uh Battleship
and his job was to protect the aircraft
or the uh
the planes from the on the aircraft
carrier and a friend of his was telling
me my dad would take it just bad if uh
they hit those uh those ships he just
thought it was he had to get everyone
and he says that if they were taking
fire he he would stay right on that gun
so yeah the the films of the World War
II U.S Navy yeah is it's crazy to watch
those things it's crazy to watch those
and they have actually both sides you
know they have the Japanese that are
coming in drop arms you can watch those
films as well yeah and it wasn't all the
big ones you know the Midway and all
that stuff and uh so it just it just uh
mentally wiped them out and he would
have these just
um just go off on us yeah yeah it's um
it's I don't think we're ever going to
have a naval war like World War II again
where it's where where the the humans
are at such a massive amount of
pressure
um I mean of course something the Navy
can always go bad I mean you know if a
vessel I mean you don't even need a war
no things can happen but but that that
World War II from a from a naval war
perspective is just it's it's horrendous
I was talking with one of my friends the
other day even just being even just
firing those big guns these guys didn't
have hearing protection you know how
many you know right now they're they're
doing all these things with football and
CTE and and po uh
you know traumatic brain injury the TBI
they tell us now in the SEAL Teams we
shoot these Rockets Carl Gustav rockets
and and they're bit they they like rock
you you know it's like you get it's like
you just got cracked in the head yeah
and now they're we used to just sit down
as a range safety officer we just sit
down out there and shoot those things
all day long and now they're saying you
can only shoot three a day and all this
stuff but can you imagine being like
your dad on a on a naval vessel with the
you're just getting concussion after
concussion after concussion
ruthless ruthless it's I don't think
people understand how uh they just take
it for granted you know you're 18 19
years old and
um or even the seals uh you guys are in
a fire fight
and then next day you go to another one
you're looking at policemen who were in
a fire fight for a half hour and they
retire you know and it's like these kids
are out there and they just get up and
do it and do it and do it my wife used
to worry us so much when we would have
these ceremonies and should meet the
seals
choose to just think how much are they
carrying around how much baggage are
they carrying around
and it's just people just don't realize
how we can just wipe a guy out and have
those memories come back and if they
just take it for granted like you say
Pros they got this for them and that and
they got these young kids that are life
and death situations carrying a hundred
pounds on their back a hundred and some
degrees and that's like they do it again
the next day and the next day it's crazy
the next day the this country doesn't
understand what these guys go through
they don't appreciate it
foreign
so you get done with Vietnam your
deployment to Vietnam you come home and
you're planning the whole time you're
gonna do your four years and punch out
yeah uh that was the plan and uh it was
funny we we were gone for 13 months and
the world really goes fast I remember uh
uh my buddy we're sitting in the car
we're gonna go get some beer I was uh I
wasn't even though I think I was 20.
and uh anyway I go in to get the bear
and uh so
as I as I go and leave I stop and I go
hey wait a minute I need a church key
and the guy goes to church key a church
key back then is what she used to open
up your candles right okay so yeah so
and the guy's looking at me and he goes
you know your church how do you open up
the beer then and he goes like this he
pulls the beer out from under the or a
soda from under the county and goes like
this she goes you go like this you know
off to the new cans had come out
I go back to the car and uh and the guy
cycle check this out guys
where have we been yeah I've had some
guys on that were pows in Vietnam yeah
and like you want you know these are
guys that got shot down in like 1965
1966 1967. they come back in
1973. it is a whole new world I mean it
was a whole new world for them uh and
even the year like I mean you must have
been gone 69 that the world changed a
lot in that year oh yeah I mean uh when
we got back they really hated us
I was stunned how many people hated us
and I'm thinking what did we do it was
come out and insult us uh you know I
remember uh uh I was at the airport and
back then you had to fly in your
uniforms and uh it's not a good idea all
the time you were like targets and I had
a woman up in San Francisco just rushed
up to me and she's got her children and
she just hates me and I don't even know
her and uh she says she says how do you
kill babies and it's like
and I started thinking why should I take
her seriously it's like well we try to
give him a little bit more lead you know
because they're quick
I'm sure she'll appreciate it oh she
didn't appreciate it but you know it's
like how long do we keep taking it yeah
yeah so uh yeah they uh it was it was
weird the way they treated us uh uh
Virginia I think they had signs dogs and
Marines stay off the grass
and I thought when are we going to learn
this lesson these guys are called and
now they volunteer to do something that
nobody else wants to do now they're
treating him a lot better which I
totally appreciate no they're definitely
you know it's definitely a different
world for us coming home now
uh so what'd you do when you got what'd
you do when you got out
uh
I was totally drifting
um
I knew I wanted I wanted to start a
business but I wasn't quite sure what I
wanted to I when I was younger I was
learning the contracting business I was
like a human wheelbarrow you know I just
never they wanted loaded up that's what
I would do so I got into Contracting and
uh then went to school at at night and
built a business
uh we did I had a partner that I went
with ever since elementary school so we
built it up to about 60 guys and then
from there I bought a
uh women's store for my sister uh who I
went through a divorce and uh I figured
she needed an income about a store for
her they really didn't make enough money
so I ended up with
um uh four stores and depart in uh in
the malls and then I decided I would
start manufacturing clothes
so it just kind of worked that way and
then I got a 300 seat restaurant bar
entertainment and everything uh was
working just great living in a nice
house had the kids and wife's happy so
you what year did you meet Sally
I met her before I uh
I uh I went overseas okay I she was a
car hop
I remember uh watching her and uh
I just love the way she looked in those
slacks you know what's a car hop a car
hop is uh
at back in the day uh you would pull up
into at a restaurant in the parking lot
and the girls would come out had little
cowboy hats on and stuff and they had
the menus so you eat right in your car
oh okay and this is where a lot of the
young guys would hang out and hang out
in their cars and go out and check
everybody's cars and you know it was
just a real social thing and I remember
uh she bends down to take the order and
I see her face and it was just weird it
was like she her front teeth are just
kind of turned in a little bit and it
just I don't know I just loved your face
and uh we knew each other for five years
uh on and off on and on when I came back
uh she was engaged to get married but it
was my fault because I thought that I
was going to go to Vietnam and the life
expectancy was not good uh sitting
behind a 50 cal in a helicopter so I
didn't want her to waste Easter time so
I says you know uh why don't you go
ahead and see other people you know I am
you know so you know good luck when I
come back and I find out she's in case
you're married
I was like thinking and then I bumped
into her at a party and
um
they just started over again and it was
nice and uh so she broke off the
engagement yeah yeah obviously done
George I've apologized to her for years
I'm so sorry
[Music]
uh okay so you had you're just basically
an entrepreneur you've got restaurants
you got clothing manufacturing and
you've got a Contracting but you got all
kinds of stuff going on yeah and uh we
had a couple of race horses which was uh
it was a lot of fun
and uh it was it was good and uh so you
had Sarah first Sarah and uh then we had
Jim and then uh Michael and then Joe Joe
we almost had in the car
but that was that was funny uh I got to
the hospital and uh
the emergency side it was that uh it was
at the Long Beach Memorial and at that
time you had to park on a slope and I
just pulled the car up and uh and I ran
into the hospital and I said my wife's
having a baby get ready and I grabbed
the wheelchair and I'd go out there and
because we were on the slope I'm trying
to get her out and the door keeps
closing and then uh so I kind of moved
myself around and then I got my hand on
the on the wheelchair and I finally get
her in and she sits back and then the
weight pushes the wheelchair back
crushes my hand my hand is now uh right
there down onto the asphalt and uh I'm
trying to uh get her back up so I can
get my hand out but it all worked out we
got her in there as soon as we got her
up to the uh into the elevator they were
right there they took her and they told
me to change my clothes I ran in and Joe
was already born
uh um
I want to read a section here from the
book uh when when Michael was born
um
you say this in the book as they gazed
upon their second son in the bright
hospital room with his inquisitive brown
eyes looking right back at theirs his
matted dark hair contrasting his fresh
soft skin George knew Michael was the
right name for him Sally wholeheartedly
agreed he was named after Saint Michael
the Archangel who in the Old Testament
cast out of Heaven all of the Fallen
Angels led by Lucifer and condemned them
to Eternity in hell
he was a soldier full of strength and
feared nothing it was a perfect fit the
hospital staff performed their newborn
well checks on little Michael and after
some time had passed the pediatrician
walked into their room Mrs monster or
Michael has jaundice which is why his
skin has a yellowish tint it's caused by
an excess of pigment typically because
of obstruction of the bile duct you will
be discharged today but we will need to
keep Michael and put him in an incubator
until his levels get lower
Sally looked back at the doctor she'd
heard what he was telling her but before
she could help herself she blurted out
doctor I'm not leaving my son that was
Sally the pediatrician fought for a few
minutes as he could see the unwavering
determination in her eyes and that she
was adamant about not not leaving him
well Mrs monster we'll let you take him
home but you have to agree to set a
protocol of treatment in the home
including sitting with him by the window
in the Sun for two to three hours a day
if you follow our instructions and he
continues to improve well not he will
not need to stay or come back to the
hospital thank you so much I will I will
do everything you you need Sally replied
so there's there's Mikey arrives on the
scene and he ends up having asthma too
yeah it just it was like from day one
Mikey Mikey's was like I always had a
problem and uh we got through that and
his skin got better and then as he got a
little bit older uh we realized he was
having breathing problems and then we
found out he had asthma but being Mikey
it wasn't it's never just a little bit I
mean it's always full-blown and it was
rough
uh for years like the asthma yeah I mean
we would check on them every night uh
fearful that you would stop breathing
and he you know he just it was just so
small and so weak because he really
couldn't exert himself and he's looking
at his uh his brothers and his sisters
our sister and they're just excelling
and uh he's just trying to keep up they
would race in the pool and uh
people are thinking they're swimming but
no Mikey couldn't swim because he would
get so exhausted moving all those body
parts so he would race them by hand over
hand along the side
he would always compete he would just
find a different way to compete
uh
and again look this book is defend Us in
battle it's it's just an outstanding
book I'm reading small chunks of it but
the the stories are just fantastic to
read
um this one I must admit I felt like I
had to read I had to read this one here
it says
as you grow older Michael was often the
target of bullying at school as well as
on the playground and began to hate it
he felt profoundly for himself the
effects of someone victimizing someone
less able to defend themselves in order
for them to gratify their own desires
even in his youngest years he was keenly
aware of the Injustice that took place
one afternoon when Michael was around
nine or ten his father took him to the
racetrack to scout out some future horse
prospects as their family raced
thoroughbreds at the time when they
arrived George began to chat with the
trainer and Michael ran off to play on
the playset Campground as he played with
the other children George noticed three
older boys pushing the other children or
children around including Michael they
made a show of it in an effort to
demonstrate to all the children that
they were in charge
they took over they took over the only
three swings and refused to get off any
of them for the smaller and younger
children to use not your swing it's mine
now they taunted the younger kids George
called Michael back to him and looked at
his tears tear filled eyes come here
Mikey I know those kids are being
bullies but not every wrong is yours to
write
there's not always Justice in the world
sometimes you just have to move on
George told Michael dad what is Justice
Michael asked his curiosity perked on
hearing the new word justice is getting
or giving what is deserved whether it's
reward or punishment Mikey George
responded to his son whom he always
called Mikey when it was just the two of
them
George could see his son taking in his
words yet his son's question continued
to cut through his thoughts as they
headed to their seats to watch the horse
race
he could see in Michael's eyes that the
issue is not resolved after the
action-packed race they returned to the
area where they met the trainer Jordan
George asked Michael to stay nearby him
and wait for him
but as soon as George was speaking with
the trainer Michael shot off to the
playground with fire in his eyes those
same boys were again back on the swings
taunting the younger children Michael
ran straight up to them from behind and
ripped each boy out of their swing one
at a time he didn't sprinted up the play
structure and began to climb the ladder
that led up to the rocket ship that had
multiple layers of slides and ladders he
knew if he could get to the top the only
one bully could get to him at a time and
sure enough they chased him right up
after and one by one he kicked each boy
backwards over and over as they tried to
attack him when he could no longer
defend himself he initiated his Escape
Plan he leaped through the top rocket
opening down the slide and ran as fast
as he possibly could back to his father
this time with the biggest grin on his
face and eyes sparkling with excitement
he knew he was safe with his father by
his side and then executed his plan
perfectly George and Michael got into
their car to head back home and George
glanced across at his son who sat in the
passenger seat victoriously grinning
back at him dad add I think that's
Justice
yeah I when I was looking at him smiling
I was thinking who was smiling the most
because it it was just this a special
day for me and I know he felt so good
that uh he outsmarted the bullies and he
just that was just in the beginning on
him and Bullies
yeah that was like a Sly move you know
that was the thing about Mikey is he was
quiet but he you could tell he was
plotting he was he was plotting so that
was like the beginning of him plotting
moves off and you figure something out
yeah
uh so
you were doing good I mean going back to
just family businesses all this stuff
got going on you're living in Anaheim
Hills which is a nice spot nice view of
the city yeah and then economy hit uh
economy and uh the IRS out and the IRS
back then before uh George Bush Senior
uh they were they had they had carte
blanche they did what they wanted and
um they would accuse you of something
and too bad uh you had to abide by it
well
I didn't owe them any money and so I
fought and it was an eight-year battle
but that battle really wiped me out and
I won I got a little piece of paper that
says George monster versus the IRS pay
nothing it might have been better off
just the right
but I was young I think I was uh 30 or
something 31 and uh so I just you know
that's wrong and I'm going to fight for
it and uh
maybe I should have negotiated but that
kind of money 800 600 plus apparently is
like eight hundred thousand dollars back
in the 70s you're talking about buying
seven or eight uh million dollar houses
in today's market yeah so anyway I
fought and then it really crushed this
uh business-wise and
um it was uh it was amazing really how
strong our family was because we went
from a pretty nice life to me coming
home one day after the banks called me
and said I have been gutted and I had 29
dollars in my pocket
and uh it was kind of struck me as like
uh
I thought I'd feel bad about it but it
was uh it was just the money was gone I
still had my family and uh
just work around it and I took uh I went
my income definitely changed
I got a job working as a security guard
and I took the job because they paid
every Friday and I wanted to make sure
my kids had groceries
and so uh I just did that until I put
some deals together and it took a while
and you moved from Anaheim Hills down to
just when you moved down to Garden Grove
yeah and this this area wasn't uh wasn't
the best
uh but it was a good experience for my
kids and uh because they would see uh
when they'd come to the factory with me
Factory was down in LA and that was a
pretty rough area and they would see
looking out the window it's you know
some of these people had it really tough
and we used to have a a bear of a man
that would sleep
front of her a friend of the door on the
porch every night
and he would he wouldn't say anything to
me it was more of a grunt all the time
and he probably had some mental problems
you're just a huge guy and I asked him I
says are you sleeping here every night
and it was just a kind of a grunt was
this of your house no this was at the
factory and down in L.A and so I thought
to myself a guy that big I got no
problem with them sleeping here at night
because it was a rough area uh so I put
I would put blankets out for him and he
he stayed there for years every morning
I would come in give it bring him a big
breakfast burrito he still hardly say
anything just Grunts and he would roll
up his uh his blankets and disappear all
day and then in the evening she'd come
back and the kids were fascinated with
this guy they wanted to be his friend
but he wasn't buying it but anyway they
kind of saw that world now uh we're in
an area where it's just a little bit of
everything a sprinkling of all kinds of
nationalities and it's it was a lower
income area
and uh
the kids were like
and then from a nice you know a high
school with all her friends are wealthy
they all go to Europe and all that stuff
which I didn't really like them around
those kids all the time because I didn't
want them to think this is the way it is
I wanted to see the other side so it was
a good experience and you've met my kids
you know they're they're good with
whoever 100 they just roll with whatever
and I and the whole family's that way so
uh it was good for them uh Sarah wasn't
thrilled with it
sorry Sarah but uh she ended up uh you
know being a leader in the on the
basketball team and all the kids did
great in sports and uh
and it was just all all in all I think
it was one of the best things that
happened well we've got a
um I guess it's uh some kind of
mythological thing in my family that
started with when I was growing up at
Christmas time apparently my mother's
dad
when Christmas would be coming he would
tell everyone it's going to be a lean
Christmas and so that's what my parents
would tell us like hey it's gonna be a
lead Christmas and then you know when I
was raising my kids and I'm in the Navy
and I you know I got three kids then
four kids like we didn't have any money
I've been telling my kids it's gonna be
a lead Christmas
and you know we get like I remember you
know we get used presents yeah and I
mean I got my my kids got used presents
all the time used surfboards used toys
everything was just used because it's
gonna be a lean Christmas but you got a
story that might that when you moved uh
down I think it might have been the
first Christmas down to Garden Grove
where you guys didn't have anybody you
were looking at a lean Christmas and you
got a story here about Mikey who goes
out and I think he cut down like he
didn't even have a Christmas tree the
deal was you guys were gonna do no
presents we're just going to have a nice
dinner and uh
we we just started to get back on our
feet and I had a deal fall apart on me
at Christmas and so my money's tied up
and I can't get it out and I just said
look uh we just moved into a house still
in Garden Grove but it was quite a step
up and uh
Michael is one of those guys he he just
kind of okay he's plotting he's plotting
and uh so we wake up
and we walk out and uh there's this uh
Italian Cypress sitting in a bucket of
uh of dirt and you put a little sparkly
things on there and there might even be
some light stuff and uh and there's a
little presence around it and uh we're
all coming in you know he says sit down
you know and he's giving us
um presents and the presents were
hilarious
um I still have the Rocks he gave me uh
Sally kept the scarf that he got with
those throwaways at the racetrack and
the kids got like fingernail clippers or
little knives and we just roared it was
just so funny and the way he presented
them you know and uh you're looking at
your kids and you're thinking these are
strong kids you know uh they get it and
they just roll with with the
disappointments but it was a great
Christmas
and then I remember when we're leaving
the house I don't know where we're going
to go but
go out and I look at get in the car and
you look in the front of the house and
it's that Cypress
so you get two cyphers on one side you
got a Cypress a half on the other
neighbors are thinking well they're ever
going to fix that you know and I I was
no it's a Memory I think that it wasn't
fixed until somebody else bought the
house
uh uh and so everyone's playing sports
Mikey end up playing hockey how do you
get into hockey that's not the Southern
California no but for him uh if it rolls
anything that rolls or slides it was
just him I don't know he was like
remember the first time he was on skates
it was like I'm looking at this guy he's
jumping over stuff he once he starts
moving it's like in his head well maybe
I can do this maybe I can do this just
like when we got him a bike uh next
thing he's building ramps you know
seeing how high he can go a ramps break
he crashes and burns
gets right back um builds another ramp
in hockey yeah I was it surprised me but
he was still smaller than the other kids
and his Edge was really uh how fast he
was on wheels
and he just really liked the sport he
got his contact but because he was on
Wheels he uh could really hit these guys
too and he was quick so uh if they hit
him he could come back and he felt
everything was equal and he loved the
game yeah
and then he also played football as well
yeah I he loved football but he was uh
you know he just he wasn't a big guy but
he had you know he's one of those guys
had a lot of heart always working uh and
uh he took it really serious no one was
going to run past him he was the
defensive end and uh that was his
territory even if he had to pull the
guy's uh face mask he was not going to
go anyplace I remember he did it and
he's double teamed and I see his head
Reach Out grab this guy's face mask and
I was sitting just right off in the
bleachers he could see me and he looks
at me like
you got to do what you gotta not on my
side uh you got a section in here you
say Michael's team was getting pummeled
by their counterpart junior varsity team
which included some of the varsity
players one by one the JV players on his
team began to remove their helmets and
quit walking off the field and defeat
and shame they were not willing to be
humiliated any longer in front of their
family or friends during the Garden
Grove football scrim image the clock
sounded its horn loud horn for half time
and each team jogged to the respective
locker rooms as George Sat by his old 64
gold Riviera
and Michael ended up with it for a while
and waited for the game to resume
Michael walked past his father with
barely a glance in his Direction George
watched curiously as Michael moved
around the front of the car and opened
the passenger door to get in George
confused as to why Michael's not headed
back to the field look directly at him
what happened Mikey why are you here
Michael looked up at his father his
whole demeanor ripe with disappointment
as he fought back tears Dad they just
quit the referee canceled the game
because too many of our players quit dad
why would they quit we still had a
chance we could have won
Mikey you guys were down by 50 points I
know Dad but the game wasn't over yet we
had a chance he hung his head trying to
Fathom what had just transpired as he
quietly repeated to himself they just
quit quitting was not something the
monsters did
they were always taught to follow
through
yeah that we were I mean I had uh when
they wanted to play a sport before I put
him in that sport we always had the same
conversation you joined this team you're
you're here until the season's over
whether you like the coach or whether
you play or not play you do not quit so
they were raised that way you make that
decision because I wanted them as as
children to understand they make these
decisions then they have to live by them
and there's just short little tests but
it was important that they started
understanding you know you just on a
whim decides you want to play football
so uh he was raised like you don't quit
and all those kids it was was hard on
them because they were just getting
wasted
I mean there was no first downs there
was no uh completed pass they were just
totally outclassed but Michael always
figures there's always a chance and if
he would have got one touchdown he would
have felt like we have our dignity
so that's he was just he did not like he
didn't mind losing as much if he gave
everything but just to lose that just
wasn't Michael he used to have a thing
he uh bunk bed he was on the bottom and
Joe was uh on the top and he even on his
uh inside when he woke up in the morning
there was a little message you know
never quit and he carried that forever
you know his whole life yeah he was he
was a believer in once you said it then
live with it yeah
uh you go on to say here Michael's
lionhearter determination grew stronger
as he Grew Older he played as a
defensive end for The Argonaut varsity
football team while he's in high school
and was known for being one of the
hardest workers on the field asthma
continued to challenge Michael but he's
not going to let it dictate how he lived
Sally remembers how Santa Anna wins
coming in from the mountains each fall
would affect Michael's breathing one
afternoon she opened the door to his
bedroom to find him wheezing she asked
him why he wasn't using his inhaler I'm
weaning myself off it Mom
although unable to fully rid himself the
ailment Mike would not let it stop him
from accomplishing what he set out to
achieve so he's just
freaking tough he is he's very
determined and I think all the the the
the way he was treated you know uh when
he was younger bullies just they have a
sense there's the weak one
and he just made it his life not to be
the weak uh weak one I mean I remember
when he was in the sixth grade he told
me he says it's going to be over
he says this will stop
oh this is the bullying he's talking
about he says this will stop
and uh he just determined to get
stronger and even verbally I mean people
didn't realize if you know him that his
tongue was sharp when he wasn't uh you
know as strong because he would go the
other way and he would embarrass them I
mean he had very good mind and uh he
would just trash them and they know that
whatever they would do he would take it
I've seen him take these hits knowing
he'd come back that's what happened and
you know his brother would say hey those
guys you know went after Mike because he
went after them verbally and you know he
would fight but he was just outgunned
but he never would back down he was
little and he had to pay you know all of
them had to have uh discipline we had
rules in the family and if he wasn't
buying the rule he would literally just
okay
um I'll take the the two days in my
bedroom or whatever in our bedroom those
bedrooms didn't have TVs and video games
but I never never beef about it or
anything you just take his medicine
there you go yeah
so he he's playing football how was
grades in high school
here's Michael I don't know Michael in
the sixth grade it was determined they
had very high IQ
and it was determined because we had a
meeting and uh uh the teacher says he
just doesn't do anything he ignores me
and he doesn't do his homework and he
goes in there look as a matter of fact
there's his backpack is he can take it
home and he goes and gets it and she's
about to take this home and in the
backpack had all these papers in it
so he opens it up teacher opens it up
and he's looking at all the homework he
did and the tests he took
he goes
he goes you know
I think your kid's really pretty smart
and that's when uh they start putting
into the to the higher classes and he
was fine with it but then he got towards
the end of high school he's bored and I
got a letter from the high school a
registered letter
this is your son uh his all F's and he's
not going to graduate
I bring him into the office and I say um
you understand this family works right I
have my job what's the office this is in
your house you have the office yeah this
is where counseling tastes takes place
with the with the children
well I spent a lot of time in there
praying that I had some money in the
bank and I just keep looking at it no
it's still the same uh and I says yeah
this works I says you have a job and the
job is uh to get through school that's
your job
and uh I said you got straight ABS
they're telling me that you will not
graduate
what do you think that's going to play
out with me
and uh I said you know you won't be
living here
you don't do your job you don't live
here you're gone
and he just smiles
he says don't worry dad
I got this
and uh
boom he turns it around Straight A's all
the way up and then uh he smiles and he
goes I told you I got it there's
something about him that uh when he's
bored then he made it harder just to you
know test himself and the things he did
when he was young was always testing
himself
he just it was almost like uh
since I had resources like having a a
young horse that she didn't allow him to
get out of the stall and he just wanted
to run and wanted to run Michael wanted
to run but he couldn't he just didn't
wasn't strong enough and once he got
stronger he just wanted to run and he
did
so so he graduates from high school what
was his plan when he graduated from high
school because he graduated in 99 yeah
and a couple years later yeah so what
was he doing in the meantime his plan uh
was to go into the military
but he wanted to have a good time before
he went into the military
so we had a good time and uh then I
remember telling him you know the good
time's over
um it's time for you to make a decision
I was was Jim in the Marine Corps at
this point
or a gym already no I can't remember I
think Jim was in the Marines yeah he was
in the Marines another one that uh
doesn't say anything to his dad uh Hey
Dad uh I'm going going I'm going to join
the Marine what do you mean to joined
the Marines well I'm going in tomorrow
what
and uh I knew Micah was talking about
going in I had no idea uh that that's
was his plan
in the book it says that it sounds like
you're the one that had kind of told him
about the SEAL Teams where he had asked
you about it asked me about it and uh I
remember uh because we would drop guys
off and would you practice things in
being in the Marines to do with navy
guys and then we had all you know we had
um our Recon guys so we do a lot of the
same things you know Recon
everyone forgot about Recon
anyway so he was fascinated with it you
know like any young kid he wanted to
hear about these guys I had no idea uh
what was going on in his head and
because he was so sickly it was he's the
last guy I thought that would be a seal
you know and I always thought to myself
he's got a great mind and this is going
to be one of those Eggheads and I'm good
with that
but his mind was not thinking that way
and I was really kind of taken back when
I I found out after he graduated from
Navy boot camp his instructor told me
his instructor told you that he was
going to try and be a seal he says you
got a great son here
he goes this guy is great and uh he's
definitely sealed material now what
is that the first time you you
knew that he was going to try and go to
buds or he was going to buds yeah he
talked about seals but it never really
registered that he was serious about
that
and uh and you know we tased him anyway
because he went into the Navy uh because
we're all Marines a whole family all the
way back to World War II Marines and uh
and it was like uh I was good with it uh
maybe but then the seal thing just
caught me like
you know and I still remember he had
that funny smile like yeah
so uh
he's in the Navy
um he ends up at buds
and buds is what it is and what it is is
freaking brutal yeah and uh
I'm gonna go to the book here it was now
late fall 2001. the days were shorter
the air was colder cooler Michael was
exhausted and decided to head home for
the weekend to get some much needed rest
in the midst of vigorous training a lot
of people don't know this when you're at
Bud's basic SEAL training people think
you get locked away on some Island
somewhere no you you basically work
Monday through Friday and then weekends
you recover yeah but if you want to
recover by drinking you can do it if you
want to recover by laying in bed and and
icing your knees you can do that too
it's kind of up to you
uh and Michael decided he's going to go
home so George knew something was wrong
as soon as Michael returned home Michael
wasn't walking right and George and as
George looked down at his feet he could
see why Michael's socks were bloody and
Michael was miserable Michael what are
you doing you're not gonna make it like
that Dad I'm not quitting Michael you
can't even walk and your feet are a
bloody mess you're leaving Footprints
all over the kitchen floor I'm not
quitting
Michael bandaged up his feet as best he
could and headed back to Coronado
prepare for training the following day
the bandages did little to keep the sand
out of the lesions on his feet and every
step he took was like running sandpaper
across the open sores bringing
excruciating pain both feet were an
absolute mess Yet Michael pushed on the
pain continued to build and was not only
draining him mentally but rapidly slowed
his Pace affecting his ability to
perform the required Evolutions he was
disgusted with what had begun to creep
into his conscious thought he hated to
see weakness in others but hated it even
more in himself with every pain-filled
step it became clearer he was forced to
acknowledge what he had tried to ignore
the reality that he would not be able to
continue
it was the 24th hour of the first day of
Hell Week the third week of the
six-month Pipeline and regarded as the
most challenging week of Bud's training
cycle when students are expected to run
upwards of 200 miles and are allowed to
allowed only three to four hours of
sleep the entire week Michael stood up
and did what he thought he would never
do he walked over to the notorious Bell
affixed to a pillar directly in front of
the first phase office and rang it three
times alerting the whole compound that
he was finished
Michael made a left face walked achingly
down the sidewalk that was already lined
with helmets of those who had not made
it to this point when he reached the end
he made one more left face took off his
helmet and placed it next to the others
he had quit
dang
it was devastated
I remember when he he told me and it's
just
I mean his eyes were just filled with
tears
I just could not believe that he quit he
just couldn't believe it
and uh it was it was just so sad and I
didn't even have words
you know I
I kind of didn't want him to be a seal I
didn't want him to be a seal but I knew
how much it meant to him especially at
that moment
I just really didn't I just I could
remember how I when they were kids I
would tell them you know it's when it's
your defeat and how do you come back
from the defeat that's what makes you
the the man or the woman is the way you
come back
and I couldn't even remember that I was
struck by he was just so sad
and so the next morning uh he's up
making some breakfast
and uh
he says remember when you say
I go yeah yeah she goes yeah I'm gonna
be a seal
and and then it began I mean it just he
was back on track and he was going to be
a seal
so
he ends up getting State and again uh
like the book has so many good details
of all this uh eventually he ends up
getting stationed in Italy yeah in Achi
treza
and immediately and he's with a couple
other guys that want that are in the
same boat he is in yeah
and um
man that program's tough
uh so they began training they began
getting ready um they're swimming
they're running their uh cliff jumping
um getting into some of this stuff here
uh for Michael and his friends they were
determined to push themselves as hard as
necessary to train their bodies for the
rigors of buds they were getting a
second shot they knew they were not
about to blow it they would do whatever
it took to be ready this time around
Michael's most traumatic experience thus
far in life was ringing the bell and
quitting Buds and he would not be
satisfied without a second chance to
prove to himself that he could do it he
told his younger brother Joe that this
second time around they would have to
drag his dead body off the beach before
he would quit that does not surprise me
with Michael
uh scared as bro you know you know Joe
was like yeah
that could be true dad
uh got some good stories in here about
Italy they're in Sicily they got
nightlife uh Michael's buying Vehicles
he buys a Russian truck he buys a he
buys a Lancia you say this uh Michael
also personalancia an incredibly fast
car with all-wheel driving used to
cruise it all throughout Italy the
higher the speed the better until one
afternoon when he when Ollie that's one
of his buddies got a call from Mike he
had crashed it racing an Audi they were
flying down the Sicily Highway when Mike
hit a wet spot and lost control his
Lancia spun and slammed directly into
the concrete divider wall luckily he
wasn't hurt and was able to get it towed
back to his home but it was not looking
good for the car Ali drove over to
Mike's apartment to see how he could
help first he saw the car it was totaled
then he saw Mike beer in hand stake on
the grill and not a care in the world it
was good while it lasted Mike said with
his signature smile that is Michael that
is a hundred percent
uh
just I mean this is just another Mike
got so many accidents in Italy he opted
to pay 200 a day for extra car rental
insurance just to cover the shenanigans
he's like he liked freaking vehicles and
cars and motorcycles that might have
been my fault uh I had a motorcycle when
I was a kid and uh I remember Sal always
would get on and then I would uh drive a
little crazy and she'd reach up into my
shirt and pull my chestnuts out
but uh Mike when he was little we had a
64 GTO oh man
and uh that thing uh
from a dead stop you know or just it
would just scream you know and Mike was
just a little guy and he'd hold on to
the the handle over the glove box and
you just go dad go and I'd burn through
those gears you know and fishtailing and
he's just in heaven you know and then uh
I would we had this long on-wrap to the
freeway we could kind of see the freeway
before you got on and you had this long
uh ramp and so he he knew I could do it
there and I would so I just burned
through the uh through the gears and the
cars and then he can smell the smoke
from the tires he's just a huge smile
that we're going 100 miles an hour you
know it's like about half of that give
or take 50. you know and look happy but
he just loved the acceleration and I I
didn't realize uh that it would have
such an effect because he loved fast
stuff yeah and he just did yeah
including lancia's yeah absolutely if
parents read this it's a great book for
your children except for you know that
kids slow it down a little bit that
might have been a mistake on my part
uh fast forward a little bit here it
says as the two years came to an end as
he inch closer to heading back to
Coronado for a second shot at buds
Michael felt strong strong and ready
Michael still contended with his severe
asthma which caused him to be rarely
without his inhaler
but he would not concede to this ailment
in any shape or form one afternoon as
Chris that's another one of his buddies
talks about and Mike ran side by side on
one of their last hard runs Mike pushed
himself harder and harder to beat his
friend Chris as Chris pulled ahead it
pissed off Mike a pissed off Mike
grabbed his inhaler chucked it across
the road and sprinted until he beat
Chris and finished the run that was the
last time Chris ever saw Mike use his
inhaler he didn't have room for weakness
it was all or nothing this time around
he was mentally ready for buds it was
like bring it uh yeah I mean and it
sounds like his attitude going in
obviously you know what to expect you
don't want to make that mistake although
uh one of my roommates was a a former
uh buds quitter and he was back again
and I was like well you know he's
probably gonna he's a little older you
know kind of
I was thinking hey you know these guys
gonna be good to go but sure enough
first night of hell he quit so there's
no there's still no guarantee it's it's
what you change in your brain yeah and
he was more prepared I remember I think
the last thing I said to him when he
left was uh watch the sand because uh
that really destroyed him he he wasn't
he just didn't take care of himself uh
that first time around
so um he was definitely determined he
was in good shape and uh mentally he was
determined yeah
um
he had a friend named Gabe Lynch yeah
and uh this kid was like an Oregon farm
boy so you had like The California Kid
yeah
um they had some pretty good experiences
that they talk about in the book that
you guys talk about in the book it says
uh
Gabe and Michael were both part of boat
crew 3 they were close in height
standing just around six foot one Gabe
recalls how Mike was always one to
brighten the mood of the guys during the
often exhausting days of being beaten by
by the ocean surf while wet and Sandy
all day long Gabe was the slower runner
between the two of them and he remembers
Mike hanging out in the back with him as
they would push through their Four Mile
timed runs he would encourage Gabe then
Sprint back up to the front and finish
easily in the top tier Runners every
time that was the kind of guy Mike was
always looking out for his buddies he
could see who needed a word of
encouragement or or action of support
and would deliver it at just the right
time sometimes that's all it took when a
guy was delirious running on a few hours
of sleep
for for days on end even though Michael
had not yet made it and become part of
the seal Brotherhood Brotherhood itself
was something he already understood in
the depths of his core he was not going
to let his friends down
and he was always that way
yeah when he was a little kid when we
were living in that uh other
neighborhood it was pretty poor I wasn't
uncommon for him to take a Christmas
gifts and give him away to his friends
I'd see his friends playing with the
gifts if you were history and if you
speak to his friends they will say that
he truly was a true friend and he was
always on their side and that's just the
way it was so the Brotherhood was
perfect for Michael it was a perfect
place yeah
um
a quick scene from hell week
uh just because this is just this
sounded like Mikey man uh with paddles
in hand they begin uh to row in unison
they've just taken the first few Strokes
in an evolution aptly name around the
world which in time entails paddling
their small boats from San Diego Bay
North through the channel around the tip
of Coronado Island back to buds Beach a
staggering 13 miles as they paddled Gabe
couldn't hold back any longer he started
to doze off and without missing a beat
Michael shouted over to him from his
side of the boat hey man I love you bro
but you need to wake up
that's all it took for to jar gate back
to Consciousness and help him Focus
uh
they end up securing how weak they lost
about 75 percent of their people
obviously
Michael made it
um
yeah rape it's uh it's just created Ray
baviera another guy from from task in
your Bruiser was it was the lpo of their
buds class
um
they're getting ready to go out to San
Clemente Island which is the third phase
of training it's the last phase of
training
and
before going out there Michael planned a
little boat trip
and again again I'm going to fast
forward to this part just because it's
it's funny to read about Michael being
an avid Adventurer had planned a spear
fishing trip and brought Gabe and
another buddy of theirs Chris Chris
Kimbrell from their buds class along for
the weekend Gabe knew how to spear fish
like Mike and they were Naturals in the
water but for Chris a Midwest landlocked
boy this Escapade was not his Forte he
was ready to go for it though and
couldn't wait to see what the
picturesque Island had to offer Chris
was one of the first all suited up and
couldn't wait to get going before Gabe
had even dropped the anchor Chris jumped
in the water to see what he could find
moments later he burst through the
surface proudly holding up his spear
there on the end of his six foot
Hawaiian sling flopped a beautiful
orange fish Chris yelled in Triumph
Michael immediately Dove for the water
tackling Chris as he pulled the spear
from his hand that's a good that's a
Garibaldi the state fish of California
it's super illegal to hunt dude Michael
yelled at Chris there were other fishing
boats all around anyone who could have
seen the fish that Chris had on the end
of his slang Michael quickly snatched
the fish from the tip of the spear and
Dove to the bottom he found a large Rock
in which so that's just like classic
poor Chris crebel uh Chris Brown who's
you know a landlocked guy you know he
didn't know he's like look what I got
yeah that's Garibaldi were everywhere
you see him you're like oh this is easy
hun
oh that's classic
um
third phase the last remaining block
again fast forwarded the last block
before graduating buds entailed
instruction on SEAL weapons and tactics
lasting around eight to ten weeks as
students covered Land Navigation land
War for ambushes and raids patrolling
weapons handling and Marksmanship and
demolition Michael and his classmates
were on San Clement Island focusing
specifically on raids ambushes and
demolition
San Clemente Island is a rocky
volcanic island off the coast of
California with hardly any trees lots of
cactus no natural fresh water full of
caves and caverns formed by gas bubbles
in the lava when the island was molten
mass as the men focused specifically on
ambushes and raids Ray baviera who
continued as Michael's Squad lpo through
third phase recalls how Mike would find
a way to make light throughout the
arduous and non-stop Evolutions bringing
humor to any situation brightening
anyone's move mood
and that's something that everybody
everybody says that about my tech no
matter what's going on he's just gonna
be sitting there uh putting everybody
back into a good mood
yeah he thought it was actually
important uh especially if people are
getting stressed out like in buds you
can see it on their faces and he thought
you know he's seeing these guys are
going on tilt you know and uh
you know I don't our family does that
you know they'll equip this and that you
know and um he's always done that when
things get real serious and it kind of
brings people down
um
so
it says third phase was coming to close
just a few weeks later and as the men
prepared to graduate they were
discussing what gift to give the command
in their memory they all want to leave
something in their name from buds Class
250 that was immovable and unique they
decided to give basic training command
an enormous Boulder with their names
engraved upon it now the class had to
figure out how to track down a boulder
engrave it and have it delivered to the
command Rey's wife Maria was back home
in San Diego and took care of the
logistics what began as an idea quickly
escalated into a four-ton Boulder that
would have to be delivered by a crane
who would end up costing seven thousand
dollars and change each guy was given
the option to back out after the final
pricing was determined and not one guy
did they were all in this together what
the final gift became was something none
of the bud students would forget
and their memory forever lives on etched
into the boulder that was engraved with
the following words the actions of the
few dictate the fate of many by
Alexander the Great and it also says the
secret to buds is underneath this rock
so
buds classes
give gifts to Buds and depending on the
class and what they do
some of the some of the gifts are pretty
awesome some of them are pretty lame
yeah uh I think my class gave a pretty
lame
we gave a PO like a little speaking
podium
beautiful yeah the story behind it was
one of the instructors was up at the
podium talking to us and as he was
talking to us he got mad and he smashed
his hands down on the podium and the
thing like exploded he like broke apart
in all these pieces and he started
yelling and we all go hit the surf and
so we like had this special one made and
the funny part about that story is years
later I I I saw that guy the guy that
had smashed his Podium and it exploded
like he was The Incredible Hulk and I
said he was a master chief by this time
and I go hey Master Chief he's like and
I go when because he was a hard dude I
go
when my class was going through and you
were the dive phase Chief I said you
smashed your hands on this Podium and it
like exploded I said was that like a was
that like a set uh was like a trick
thing
and he looks at me and he goes negative
it was Oak reinforced and I was like
okay uh
so people give these various different
gifts and people give some some stuff's
really cool probably the most famous one
is the the Creature from the Black
Lagoon it's a life-size statue of the
creature the Black Lagoon and it says so
you want to be a frogman a little sign
hung on it but this was an awesome gift
it's this massive freaking rock yeah
it's going to be there for a while it's
not going anywhere and so that's what
they gave
um
I didn't see that uh until uh ratio that
Timmy we were invited to watch uh hell
week with uh the seals we watch it from
on top of a roof on one of the buildings
and then
fishing I'm so sorry for those guys you
know it's like both poor guys
people should just see that knowing
these guys are doing it because they
want to do it it's just amazing what
they go through but after after that
then he showed me the rock I knew it was
there but I never really
you know I just yeah there's a rock you
know and then it went over and showed me
and um and it was nice and I could see
where they they were they were rubbing
on the names and the obviously they were
rubbing a lot on Michael so it was kind
of nice no it's awesome and it's in a
really prominent spot it's like as you
as you leave the compound to go to the
beach or come back you go right by The
Rock
uh
Michael graduated buds on September 2nd
2004. back on Coronado Island California
the graduation day was memorable for all
the men stood proudly in their cream
clean crisp dressed uniforms and each
waited in anticipation for their name to
be called across the compound a giant
crane labored with a four-ton Boulder
carefully placing a large Rock in the
much deliberated position where its
weight could not would not crush the
buried utilities below it
Michael's parents George and Sally as
well as three siblings Jim Sarah and Joe
were in attendance to celebrate the
achievement George recalls the smile on
Michael's face as he walked up to
embrace and fall in the ceremony he had
this look on his eyes that seemed to say
to me dad I hope you didn't doubt me I
told you I was gonna do this and I did
it I Told You So I love seeing him like
that it gave me so much joy I never
wanted him to join the seals but I was
so proud to be proved wrong by my son I
love it when my kids uh prove me wrong
because it's kind of a challenge
I don't think you can really do that you
know I mean I don't I don't I don't know
if you could do that and I love it when
they come to me and say I did it and you
don't know nothing and I I mean they I'm
sure they catch on but to see my kids
stick to something all of them and then
they accomplish it it's just you know
yeah yeah you feel great yeah how did
you feel when you got through hell week
the second time you must have been like
okay
thank God yeah
it was funny I I kind of though his
attitude I really would have been
surprised if he didn't
because he had these friends too and
once he makes these friendships
um he's going to be with them and push
them through so uh I just I I really I
would have been more surprised if he
didn't make it yeah that's the wild
thing I mean you start out with a couple
hundred kids in your class they're
quitting so fast that they're just it
you don't even know what's happening
yeah and and so you got to be a little
bit careful because if you don't
if you'd get to know someone kind of
while you're there and all of a sudden
they quit yeah that also you go I'm
alone so for him to have some good
friends rolling in there's definitely
nice and
yeah
got another guy here Michael and z
went through all of buds together they
got they graduated Bud's basic Airborne
seal qualification training now assigned
to Seal Team three Z to Echo platoon and
Mike to Delta platoon
the weeks were busy training and the
weekends were spent riding their bikes
and that's motorcycles by the way
chasing girls hanging out with the guys
after a day of riding they'd often come
back to connect and unwind at bar
Dynamite a small barn Mission Bay where
they'd grab drinks with friends
including Gabe and other freshly minted
and another freshly minted seal Tommy D
Mike was Mike was living life to the
fullest he was renting this house in
Mission Bay while the new guys like
myself lived in one small bedroom small
one-bedroom apartment said Z laughing a
motorcycle and a stellar pal pad were
not the only things Michael said his
sights on he was eyeing his next car and
he knew exactly what he wanted just
received a contract bonus that he used
to buy a silver 2004 Corvette
[Music]
z06.
Michael could never be a financial
advice this is like the classic thing I
tell guys not to do when they get their
bonus I used to be like Hey listen don't
go buy a Corvette don't go buy a Ford
350 super duty Harley-Davidson don't
don't do that no it's hard to talk about
it I know especially with the junkers
that my cat
oh so he's got that
uh Mike was living the dream in Southern
California
but he also understood his team was on
short fuse to Surge into combat areas in
the Middle East he knew the coming
months would include a fire hose of
information intense training and
Splatoon was going to war and how fast
he learned and integrated into platoon
and his role could mean all the
difference
yeah he took that real serious when he
was home he was studying he definitely
uh he got to the point where I do not
want to make a mistake
I mean it was like he really wanted to
make sure that he was on it
yeah and and it was so long ago for me
like when you're a new guy there is so
much it's just stuff to know and
you don't want to make a mistake
everyone's watching you and you just
want to do good and you're going to be
counted on you know these guys are going
to be counting on you so
uh and we also had a condensed workup
because at the time the war was hot and
heavy this is now 2005 going into 2006.
the used to be 18 months to train and
get ready to go on deployment well for
us it was six months like or sorry 12
months boom and you're out the door so
they it was everything was compressed
and there was a lot of stuff being being
forced down the throats of everybody and
uh
yeah there's a there's a story in here
about the the Roger that which which
so I'm I'm talking to new guys and it
was a particular block of training where
it's close quarters combat the
instructors are it's live fire and Close
Quarters which means you're shooting
right next to guys right you know you're
two feet from someone you're shooting of
12 inches off their muzzle it is tight
quarters it's super dangerous and so you
got to be heads up and the instructors
have to be
really hard to make sure that you don't
mess anything up
and so I had took the new guys and said
listen when you're going through this
block of training those instructors tell
you something
you your response is Roger that now I
don't want to hear like well I just I
was thinking this or I could have done
where I didn't see no does he don't say
any of that
will the instructors talk to you you say
Roger that
and so we're going through this training
and as we're going through this training
you know I'm friends with all the
instructors all the instructors are like
oh we're all friends but the new guys
don't really know him that well but
finally one of the instructors who's a
good as a master chief he comes up he
goes he goes hey Jocko what's up with
this monster guy and I was kind of I
didn't really know
something was wrong and I go what do you
mean
Mikey's you know he's good to go he's
like well what's up with his attitude
and I go what do you mean what's wrong
with his attitude and he goes every time
I tell him something or one of the
instructors tell him all he does look up
at us and say Roger that that's all he
says and I go hey bro I told him that's
all he's supposed to say and he's just
following that to a t that's what he's
doing and when he would say that so uh
the guys that he's with are like kind of
smirking like no one knew if he was a
smart ass or he's just following your
orders that's a I'll tell you so here's
another similar story
we're you were in the Humvees and this
we're going through the block of
training with Humvees and the the
Gunners call out you know like clear
right like you come up to an
intersection and the Gunners which is
Mikey call out clear right or clear left
and you know Mikey's up there and I'm
I'm the I'm the vehicle Commander so I'm
sitting in the in the passenger seat and
he's up there and like we get to our
first time doing it
and we come up to an intersection and
he's like clear right I could barely
hear him you know and I look down at him
or I look up and I kind of hit him on
the leg I was like hey man you got a
sound off
and he's like he goes Roger that next
intersection we pull up to it and he's
like Claire right super over
compensating and I thought to myself
hold on a second yeah
is he being a wise ass or and then we
pulled the next intersection Claire
right and and here's the thing he wasn't
being a wise ass who I told him to
freaking sound off if you want it you
will get it I got it
but that was uh you know that attitude
that Roger that attitude man that's um
that that was it you know that was he
was gonna he was gonna get it done uh
one of the first blocks of training
work up was land War for out at nylon
California
by the Salton Sea with 107 degree summer
average it's a scorching place to train
and sure enough we were out there in the
summertime
this combined with the schedule Rocky
mounted terrain scarred with washes
makes the literal and figurative
Crucible of the workup here's where the
platoon will work on the tactics
techniques and procedures of fighting an
open terrain as well as demolitions
rockets and mortars and all the
different Small Arms weapon systems of
the seal Arsenal a platoon is normally
made up of 16 to 20 operators each
having a specific role to include
snipers preachers communicators and
automatic weapons Gunners to name a few
although specialized within the platoon
each man is still responsible to be
proficient at the other jobs Michael and
the other new guys could not wait to
jump right in and get started Michael
caught on very quickly especially with
his automatic weapon the mark 48. each
of the new guys were being watched
closely by the older men in the platoon
his lpo Doug Wallace remembers how that
even though Michael is quickly picking
up on the tactics and Performing all
tasks efficiently and without complaint
it was always with humility and a
willingness to learn more misery loves
company and nylund is a block where
there's many reasons to complain of our
intense conditions Mike never did one
once not one time it showed Great
Character and understanding on his part
especially for a new guy Doug said
and then there's another section here so
it's
there's like a little gang mentality
going on and part of it is like you're
gonna fight each other sometimes yeah so
they're having some boxing
matches and I'm using that term very
Loosely yeah this is not professional
because they're not professionals but
they'll set up like a tournament and
generally or oftentimes just the new
guys have to fight each other
um
so this is going down and it says it
says here it came down to Mike the last
standing new guy from Delta's and
someone's asking approves of his two two
platoons Charlie and Delta it came down
to the last standing new guy in Delta
which was Mike versus Kevin lace
the final remaining new guy in Charlie
Kevin was huge 225 pound Tower of muscle
who loomed over most Team guys at a high
to six foot three Mike was much smaller
and more slender but he wouldn't give up
he was a lean Scrappy dude recalled
Kevin I remember hitting him as hard as
I could but there was no shaking him we
had no boxing form we were street
fighting at that point with boxing
gloves on I looked at him and it seemed
as if his eyes were crossed and I
continued to hit him over and over again
but he wouldn't stop he returned blow
after blow right back we got so into it
that I'm sure we were both seeing red
but each of us refused to back down both
platoons cheered and taunted as each man
hit the other over and over again clad
and only their boots and camo pants the
two men continue to brawl neither could
defeat the other and in the end the
older men called it a tie Kevin had
hugged Mike once they stopped and cooled
down you're a tough son of a Mike
Kevin said laughing yeah and Kevin lace
is just like a giant dude thick and uh
there's Mikey and Mikey he got jacked
later but at this point just coming out
of buds he was pretty lean still yeah
even though yeah he was yeah there
wasn't uh he wasn't a real big guy
when he just got out he was definitely
lean though yeah endurance wise guy
could go for a long time but mentally
I'm not surprised that he hung in there
because he went through those mental
things as a kid people messing with him
and stuff mentally he was just really
very strong yeah yeah
um
so we that's what we're doing it we're
going through this work up we do land
Warfare we do Mobility we do Close
Quarters combat
we do Urban Warfare at Fort Knox we're
used to do it at Fort Knox we do diving
we do jumping we do a bunch of stuff
back in San Diego and and we're working
hard that's what we're doing
and
we actually at the beginning of our
training cycle we as tasking to Bruiser
didn't know where we were deploying to
no
because there was three task units one
of them had already been designated to
go to Iraq because they went to the
Pacific the last time so it was between
my task unit
and another task unit to see who is
going to go to Iraq of course everybody
wants to go to Iraq everybody wants to
go fight the other one the other
platoon's going to do a different
Mission but it's not fighting it was the
Philippines it was because I said to
Mike I says well maybe you get lucky and
go to the Philippines he looked at me
like you poor from a very cool man no
yeah exactly so no one wants to go to to
the Philippines no one wants to go to
the southeast Asia everyone wants to go
to Iraq um and it's a basically a the
commanding officer is going to pick and
we we pushed hard and we were
supposed to go to Baghdad our original
deployment was to go to Baghdad and
there was a mission in Baghdad
that was working directly with this
group called the Iraqi counterterrorism
Force the ictf Iraqi counter these are
local I mean Iraqi guys and they had
been really well trained they're
probably the best well the best trained
of all Iraqi troops they had really nice
gear they had uniforms like they had
everything
and there was a there was a group of
seals with them and there's a group of
army army Special Forces guys all
working with these Iraqis and
I actually went on a pre-deployment site
survey we call it I went before we went
on deployment to go and meet up with
those guys see what the mission was like
get a heads up on everything
because that's where we're going going
to Baghdad
so I come back from that we're prepared
we know what our mission is
and where everyone goes on
pre-deployment leave so everyone goes
you know like Hey we're okay we're going
on deployment soon and that's when we
got the whole deployment changed around
and my commanding officer is calls me
and he's like hey
you're not you guys aren't going to
Baghdad anymore you guys are going to go
to ramadi and
well ramadi we knew ramadi was the worst
place in Iraq and everybody wanted to go
there just like everyone wanted to go to
Iraq well everyone want to go to ramadi
I mean the commanding officer said it to
me like I was gonna be sad now the the
the the mission in Baghdad was a cool
Mission too and it was kind of all set
up and running so it was kind of is like
ready made like you know what you're
going to be doing ramadi was kind of the
Wild West still but when he he said it
to me he was making it seem like he
needed to convince me
that hey this is what this is what's
going to happen you know are you okay
with that and I was like I realized the
kind of the tone of his voice acts kind
of like well you know sir I'm gonna need
some more people I'm gonna need some
more gear
yeah uh but he was great and and then we
reshuffled and
um
we reshuffled and got ready to go and um
I don't even I don't think I even I
think
I don't even think we notified the guys
because everyone was on leave
and you couldn't tell them like on in a
on a non-secure net net like Hey we're
going to Ramada now like it's classified
so they everyone came back we had
another week or whatever
um I was like hey everyone we're not
going to bed anymore we're going to
ramadi
um and the guys were ecstatic they're
ecstatic
uh
and this some of the stuff you cover in
the book Sarah and Sally come down to
help Mikey pack up all this stuff uh he
he takes he takes his mom for a little
ride in the Corvette gotta read about
that one
uh he did it on the motorcycle too oh
but she was used to the bike with me on
when I used to take her on my bike so he
was kind of disappointed because she
didn't get scared that was nice
have a nice day and be careful
uh
he goes up to Garden Grove
um spend the last couple days up there
and
I'm gonna read this uh the time had come
George and Michael awoke early in the
morning and drove back down the I-5
South to San Diego the trip seemed to
pass much faster than either would have
liked once they arrived in Coronado
George gave his son a big final hug as
he said goodbye with a kiss on the cheek
George felt the knot deep down in his
stomach but he refused to acknowledge it
the idea that this could be the last
time he saw his son was not something he
wanted to think about
as George drove home he recalled an
evening with his son from two weeks
prior
he lit up a Fuente cigar for Michael and
himself on their front porch they sat
together in silence amid the cool air
under the dark sky while smoke slowly
drifted in the light Breeze
George's voice broke the silence to
address what they were both thinking
Mikey what if something happens to you
it's not exactly a walk in the park over
in ramadi right now
please don't be a hero just do your job
Dad no matter what happens I have no
regrets
this reassurance from Michael helped
but George still did not want Mike to go
as a marine vet George saw firsthand
what Ward did to all those involved and
he despised it he knew it was
unforgiving and brutal and how it could
degrade and break the spirit he also
knew that Mike had been trained well by
men who understood what he could be
facing this brought some consolation to
George as they finished their cigars
together that night George and Mike
George looked at Mike and the man he had
become he was so proud of him from a
determined little boy who fought against
the Injustice of bullies in his own
physical weakness of asthma he
persevered and overcame failure
adversity and blocks of training he
despised such as free fall parachuting
and communication school all with
focused conviction
and often a mischievous smile on his
face
he uh
he definitely uh
surprised me
at that at that age his maturity and
he knew who he was
um he talked to kids at his age in their
early 20s and stuff like that and
they're still lost
he had his morals he had his beliefs
pretty Rock Solid and if there were
things that he didn't like I remember
like jumping on the planes I used to do
that too and uh
we talked to me about it and then he
said I don't like this I don't like it
at all and he says when he came back he
planned on just doing that because
anything that he was afraid of he would
just keep doing it and doing it till he
owned it and that's just the way he was
oh
and he didn't like communication school
no it was hard and he was studying all
the time he says God I can't screw this
up you know
going to the book Mike loaded up his
gear and followed his teammates to the
waiting C-17 aircraft the C-17
multi-purpose aircraft can be configured
for transport of troops cargo or a
combination of both this last
configuration is often how special
operations unit traveled through the
small footprint and nature of their
mission sets to you Bruiser was no
exception and as soon as the aircraft
was at altitude Michael and his friends
broke out their nylon hammocks and
ground pads and settled in for the long
flight
it's asking if Bruiser landed out to
catam airport in Iraq where they began
to prepare for a short flight West to
ramadi after the C-17 was unloaded each
operator opened his War box and donned
his combat equipment Michael had done
this hundreds of times throughout workup
and his prior training trips this time
was different this was not training his
enemy was now hardened warfighters whose
will and resolve would be used to
exploit weakness in order to win the war
um
it says here in the spring of 2006 the
Battle of hamadi was just beginning and
it was already intense
the city was arguably the epicenter was
inarguably the epicenter of the
Insurgency in Iraq and known throughout
the area as the most dangerous city in
the world wrote Leif bab and the officer
in command of Charlie platoon tasking a
Bruiser the al-Qaeda leader in Iraq Abu
musabs are Cowie
declared during that time that ramadi
would be the capital of his envisioned
Islamic caliphate in Iraq insurgents
controlled over two-thirds of the city
itself and certain areas were nearly
impenetrable to United States and Iraqi
Security Forces U.S Marines and army
soldiers that were currently over there
battled continually with large groups of
well-armed and well-organized enemy
Fighters so far 93 U.S service members
had been killed in action and hundreds
more were wounded in nearly 15 months of
fighting
you remember uh Michael Fuente I think
his name was yep he was telling me that
uh
the media would not even cover that he
was the only guy he says they were just
blowing those guys away and nobody would
go
the media so my previous deployment was
in Baghdad there was like hotels with
CNN and you know all the news
ramadi no than anybody no there wasn't
anybody and
you know I just I just had a guy on the
podcast named David bellavia he's a
Medal of Honor recipient from Fallujah
um he was in the the Second Battle of
Fallujah when the Marines pushed through
yeah and he he's one of the few people
that did go to ramadi as a report as a
journalist
and we're sitting here
you know his story you know about the
Second Battle of Fallujah it was a
brutal fighting
and David bellavia sits here and and
says oh ramadi was way worse which I
look I'm not trying to compare the two
no but yeah but they were both of that
story yeah those stories yeah I
definitely I felt so bad for those
Moorings you know and then uh well
ramadi like I yeah uh Micah would tell
me that uh
they told the family that he was just
teaching the guys how to March yeah yeah
but we could uh see the news every once
in a while you know or when uh when his
the pictures came out on the internet
you know uh for uh 40 when he had those
uh pictures out he was out there taking
pictures and and we saw him on the
internet and it's like well
the Mikey's
that doesn't look like you're training
people how to March yeah I don't see
anybody marching not other than some
guys then they're not marches
oh
yeah I mean so it was basically on as
soon as we got there you know the one of
the indicators of that was
the couple days after so I had already
been there for a little while with a few
of the guys just we were we got there
before the rest that's asking it but as
soon as the whole tasking was there
within a day I think it was like the
night they got there we had like a
little attack on our base and we end up
the whole freaking task units on the
roof of our building
lighten up and engaging You Know The
Enemy Fighters out there
and it was like okay that's what it is
um that's how it's going to be
uh almost within a couple days of being
there
I was going to meet the Brigade
Commander a guy named colonel gronsky
and I was literally walking in to meet
him and as I'm walking in to meet him we
had already put out a sniper OverWatch
position and Tony afratty the Charlie
platoon chief
had shot and killed an IED and Placer in
an area where the Marines had just hit a
big ID and lost a bunch of guys and as
soon as that happened Colonel gronsky
looked at me I mean so that's how I meet
him he says
I think your guys just killed a an ID in
place where I just lost Marines hey
Roger that sir he says we need you out
in eastern ramadi a place called The
malab out correct Corregidor
and I said Roger that you know
um and that's what we did as soon as so
as soon as I get back we plan all right
they need us in Eastern ramadi and I
took a probably two-thirds of the task
unit over to Camp Corregidor where the
first the 506 is
again as soon as we get look we've been
on the ground for like a couple days now
maybe it's been like six days and we're
over there
we get to Camp Corregidor the snipers
are like hey we can we get in the towers
because there's towers around Camp
Gregor I'm like absolutely tell the army
guys you good with us putting snipers
colonel colonel Clark said absolutely
they start killing guys almost
immediately
um enemy rocket teams mortar teams IED
in placers
um
and at the same time we're out at Camp
Corregidor for a couple days the living
conditions are terrible living the life
it was like dirt floors there's
mosquitoes
uh you know they're getting mortared
indirect fire on a regular basis just
just it was just freaking horrible no
showers just it was horrible
and so we do this initial Mission out
there
and we come back to the bigger base
and the Army's like hey thank you for
coming can can we
can you keep working with us as a matter
of fact our company Commander these guys
went out on patrol and this company
Commander with a couple with an army
company Commander he comes back after
his first Patrol with my guys and I walk
with him to the Battalion commander and
he tells the tank commander I don't want
to do another Patrol without seals with
me you know I want seals on every Patrol
so Colonel Clark is looking at me like
hey well can you get some guys out here
I said let me sort it out so now I'm
talking to Seth
and you know Seth's like hey I want to
pick the guys to to go back out there
because I however it All Shook out Seth
had to had was the opportune guy or the
the he had the the lathe had already
been assigned a guy this guy had been
already been assigned Iraqi troops to
work with another guy been assigned
Iraqi troops Worth to work with I think
Seth's the Iraqi troop Seth was supposed
to work with originally quit like they
didn't show up
and so Seth was the guy that had the
capacity so I said all right you're
gonna go out to Camp Corregidor and he
says I just want to pick the guys I want
to take and I said hey man
it's it sucks out there I said how about
we do this let's put a volunteer list up
and if anybody wants to go back out
there then then you can get volunteers
that way you're not forcing it down
their throats so that's like all right
so bring the task unit together
and I'm like all right guys you you you
all just came back from Camp Corregidor
we're going to send a element out there
for deployment
all I can tell you is it's gonna suck
the living conditions are awful the the
the level of violence is extremely high
as you all saw
and if you want to go back there then
put your name on this list on the
Whiteboard and I walked out of the room
and I came back 15 minutes later and
everybody's name was on the list
including Michael's which meant that
Seth got what he wanted which was he
just got to pick his guys yeah and um
Mikey was the was was one of the guys
there's no question he was going with
Seth yeah that that would that would
have surprised me if you didn't
yeah Nelson there was a you know uh Seth
and Tommy D and Mikey were real tight so
I knew that those three were gonna three
were gonna stick together so he didn't
care uh Seth was a little shocked at uh
Michael's decorating I remember when he
got back he was telling me about his his
Pad oh yeah well that's the good news is
the good news is once they got over
there and settled in yeah and we'll get
to that part but they eventually squared
away which seals are really good it
seals good at we got some rough living
we'll fix it up yeah
uh but that but so they end up taking
the small element of guys out there to
go to Camp Craig or move in there
working with the first of the 506 the
The Band of Brothers which was awesome
and they get settled into this
operational Tempo and settled in to
really what it is that they're going to
be doing there
um
and I'll just example of this
um they get settled into what they're
doing there gets settled into the combat
operations and real quickly
we go to the book here the Army Captain
sat peacefully in silence in one of the
only places set apart from the chaos and
violence that was now ramadi Iraq he was
a little old for the rank of Captain but
that was not uncommon for a person with
his specific duties in the military he
had spent years in formation and
training and was now here in the thick
of battle in ramadi
the quiet was broken by a firm knock at
the door the man Rose from his seat and
moved to receive it he opened the door
to find a tall brown eyed dark-haired
young man patiently waiting are you a
Catholic priest
I am replied father Halliday nice to
meet you I am a Catholic and my name is
Michael Monsour I'd like to go to
confession
father Halliday grabbed his stole and
motion Michael to follow him father
Halliday was 40 years old at the time of
his deployment to ramadi and was an army
chaplain with the first the 506th
his main mission was to assist the
soldiers of Camp Corregidor to worship
according to their own religion and
preference but was an ordained Catholic
priest and was happy to oblige Michael's
request for confession they sat down in
the makeshift shift Chapel Michael had
just arrived in ramadi and father
Halliday understood well the situation
the men were facing on a daily basis he
thought it showed significant religious
formation and conviction for Michael to
seek him out after only recently
arriving in ramadi
yeah Michael uh he took his face serious
and he also I mean he knew he was in a
place where
he could lose his life and he wanted to
be prepared
everywhere
spiritually physically mentally
yeah and the I mean the fighting was it
was sustained Urban combat and
um I I mean guys were getting wounded or
killed just about every day and and the
first the 506 I mean Charlie Company the
first the 506 who Mikey spent a lot of
time working with
they had had like a third of their
company
casualties
in four or five months so they 50 guys
they were down not all of them were
killed but it was
it was
it it was war yeah
well when we were in Fort Campbell
and uh
their Commander brought in some of the
guys that worked with Michael in their
stories you know and it's like you start
realizing how many people they did lose
uh and just how tough it was
and I remember Sally breaking down
hearing some of those stories and
thinking about Michael
so it was people just don't get it how
tough it was over there
some of what they were experiencing here
they were in the middle of intense
firefights on almost daily basis
the operating Tempo they were facing
required hyper focus and the guys
completely undeterred stepped up and
went to work we asked a lot of our guys
especially with the numbers of missions
we were conducting while facing extreme
heat dehydration and exhaustion it
didn't phase them they all stepped up
and performed Mike cirelli said
there were Army and Marine units also
stationed in ramadi that the seals were
providing assistance to in one of the
large army battalions being the first of
506.
this was The Descendant from the band of
brothers from World War II the Battalion
was huge and led by Lieutenant Colonel
Ron Clark his men were professional
talented and worked incredibly well with
the seals
Michael's troop Commander Lieutenant
Commander Joko Willington instructed his
men to use Army to use the Army's
uniform a tri-color gray digital pattern
called Army Combat Uniform or acus it
was very different from the tri-colored
desert Naval special Warfare uniform the
men wore it and even shaved their heads
to match their army Brethren this was
not only this not only increased the
cohesion of the two units but also had a
very practical Purpose By blending in
with the army unit the seals did not
stand out as special forces the enemy
had begun to Target soldiers that looked
or dressed differently than the average
so that's why when people see pictures
of that element they're wearing they're
wearing army uniforms
um that's what it is
they wanted to blend in yeah and wanted
to not stand out and wanted to form a
relationship with the Army you know
there's just just
sometimes in Special Operations you know
you could wear all this Gucci gear and
it's like you're trying to set yourself
apart and we didn't want to do that how
often does that happen where uh I see
you guys working with the Marines but
working with the Army is that something
that's uh unusual or Not Unusual I would
say it's not it's not unusual to this to
this amount on this this much of a
relationship working all the time is is
a little less common uh
but
I mean that whole deployment was we
didn't do any missions well we did
barely any missions where we weren't
with an army or Marine Corps unit or at
least adjacent to them at I mean if we
were definitely adjacent to them
um
but yeah the ACU thing that was because
that was because those guys were living
with them and we just figured let's just
win in Rome yeah
like
starting to get into this little the
order of battle for the seals would
largely consist of word coming from the
Army 48 hours ahead of time informing
them on what area of ramadi they would
be patrolling the seals would then plan
and provide sniper OverWatch during the
Army Patrol even amid their overloaded
operating schedule the men of Delta
platoon gathered supplies to build a
home away from home in the tattered
building where they would be spending
the deployment they nicknamed it full
metal jacket so the building that they
lived in called Full Metal Jacket if
you've seen the movie Full Metal Jacket
that's what this building looked like a
bunch of army guys living in there too
a plywood floor was laid the walls were
reinforced with sandbags foam was
sprayed between the inner and outer
layers for insulation they framed and
built out rooms for each man and
installed a small AC unit to keep cool
the air
in certain parts of the building the men
needed to watch their step in order to
expose to avoid exposed rebar
the heat was miserable in May reaching
upwards of 115 degrees and fixing up and
finishing Full Metal Jacket was a
welcome reprieve the men of Delta
platoon had this once barely standing
building a home away from home by normal
standards nothing to write home about
but nonetheless a Haven in the midst of
the Heat
foreign
and just to you know we were talking
about
um
this was probably a month in and I I had
the marine or sorry the Army Special
Operations Commander
came to visit task unit Bruiser
and I was briefing him on what was going
on
and I said
my element in Corregidor
has been out their last 23 missions
they've been engaged by the enemy 23
straight missions in a row and as I'm
saying that almost as if On Cue
one of the guys from my tactical
operations center comes in and and says
excuse me sir and I'm like yes and he
says just to let you know the guys in
Corregidor are in contact with the Enemy
right now and I looked at the the
siegeason of commander and I said well
sir make that 24. that's to sort of go
out 24 operations in a row
and be in enemy contact it's what you
were talking about earlier
and I remember actually the 25th
operation
I think it was the 25th operation they
didn't have enemy contact us because
they did something like really small
and they broke their streak but
um it was
it was on
uh and you got and again you interviewed
a bunch of people for this
the deafening noise of machine gun fire
suddenly erupted from an enemy Insurgent
position to the right Michael dropped
into his Field of Fire identifying the
enemy position immediately sent back a
long burst with his Mark 48 contact
right multiple seals yelled as they sent
round after round toward the enemy Mike
Sprint into the closest position to
cover which was a courtyard wall of a
nearby house and picked up fire
the other seals and the Iraqi Army
Scouts moved into the courtyard and
began returning fire as well changing
yelled Mike as he stripped out an empty
ammo box and loaded a full one just as
he closed the feed tray cover five enemy
Fighters moved to flank Michael and his
team they are flanking to the West Mike
yelled as he fired at the maneuvering
insurgents he caught them halfway
through their movement and had them
pinned behind a small vehicle hold them
there Mike JP yelled
Mike could overhear the Marine angle the
Marine air Naval gunfire liaison company
anglico guys on the radio setting up for
a strike on the enemy Fighters he had
pinned down Cass in 30 seconds called
out the controller letting the guys know
the Jets were 30 seconds out from
dropping for Michael to seemed like an
eternity he had the best vantage point
to keep the enemy where they were as the
other seals and Scouts were still
engaging the original enemy position he
conserved his ammo knowing a Reload may
give the insurgents just enough time to
maneuver away from their current
position which could cause the close air
support strike to have to abort and
start over he continued to send five to
eight round bursts into the vehicle
one away 10 seconds to impact called out
the controller the dust was heavy but
Michael could still see to know that
none of the five enemy had left the
position suddenly a flash then the car
ripped apart and disappeared in a cloud
of black and gray smoke good HIT stand
by for BDA stated the controller over
the radio the dust cleared where the
sedan used to be was a crater with
indistinguishable metal debris and other
scattered and other materials scattered
in the area Michael could make out three
of the five enemy now lying in Peculiar
positions near the blast site Good Hits
five by ekia Michael heard the
controller Say the original enemy
position went quiet immediately after
the strike the seals Marines and Scouts
maneuvered to assess and secure the
building the scouts entered and cleared
it only to find that the enemy had left
the area alright guys there's nothing
left here let's Charlie Mike said g
Fortin and the seals and Scouts moved to
re-establish their security position for
the main element
so that's what they were doing
yeah I would get uh phone messages and
where uh Michael would call would miss
them with even message just kicking back
with with my Bros uh send cigars
critical information sent cigars exactly
uh
there's there's a there's really good
examples of this throughout the book
another one immediately enemy fire began
to hit the wall around the rooftop
Michael repositioned toward the contact
and fired the enemy were using the cover
of surrounding houses effectively and
continued to harass the security
position it was clear this was not like
other attacks it was well coordinated
the enemy was careful not to engage from
the same spot for too long and continued
to maneuver and flank the rounds from
Mike's 48 began to eat chunks out of the
corners and Ledges that the enemy were
using his cover the short rooftop wall
was beginning to degrade as well however
and bullets were penetrating the plaster
in some areas the men stayed low and
continued to engage Michael was glad he
had prepped his extra ammo ahead of time
it looked as though he would be needing
it soon Michael and the other seals on
the rooftop were not the only ones
taking fire the Iraqi Army Scouts were
trying to exit the house to maneuver on
the insurgents but were pinned inside
every time one of the scouts tried to
exit the house a hail of bullets hit the
area around the exit on the rooftop the
situation was not improving and it
looked like ammunition might soon become
a problem not from Michael he continued
to engage multiple enemy positions
stopping only to reload and reposition
Mikey how's your ammo yelled JP I'm good
to go damn bro carrying all that extra
weight might save all our lives JP
smiled but he was really dead serious
Michael's 48 continued to eat away at
enemy positions an indistinct yell came
from the right Michael turned to see one
of the enemy insurgents trying to cross
the street towards the Seal's positions
he sent a burst and the enemy fighter
fell against the hot pavement motionless
with this the momentum changed and
Michael moved from position to position
engaging the enemy on three sides he was
the only aw Gunner on the roof and
although the other seals were holding
their own as well the 556 millimeter M4
doesn't have quite the same effect as a
762 millimeter belt fed machine gun
the enemy was losing and it began to
show the volume of fire had drastically
decreased and was much more sporadic
until only one enemy position was still
active the seals and Scouts concentrated
fire on the spot
the area went quiet and the men waited
for another attack but it never came and
all Michael had fired more than 600
rounds of ammunition and was likely the
reason that the security position was
not overrun
seven enemy lay dead without one seal or
Scout injured
a lot of rounds yeah I don't know I
think I've told you this story before
but I was a I went over the correct
order to check in on everybody and as
soon as I get there I was like okay go
watch Mikey's video
so I'm like cool so I go over I'm like
you know go to Mikey's Palace which is
his little room you know he's got he had
some kind of like red curtains so yeah
those are orange I don't know what he
probably took them from a house out in
town his brother sent him to him oh
there you go he goes uh we're sitting so
I think this will fit
yeah so I go in there and and uh I'm
like Mikey let me see your video and you
know he gets out and he's just showing
it to me on his he had a camera a video
camera and but you know this is when the
video cameras had just started to have
their own little screens and their own
little speakers so I'm watching it and
this is the famous video at least it's
famous in our task unit where Mikey's
like filming there's freaking everyone
shooting there's bullets flying
everywhere and then Mikey turns the
video camera back at himself and he says
it's the moolav which was never seen
that oh you haven't seen that oh man we
got to get that to you yeah so Mikey's
filming this fire fight
and as he's filming you know it's a
pretty good fire fight and then he turns
the camera back at himself and he's got
a big smile on his face and he goes it's
the mulab or welcome to the moolob or
something like that which the the
district was called the malab District
but he says it's the moolob and so I'm
watching it you know I'm I'm like Mr
serious and so I'm but I'm trying to
hold back but I'm smiling and then he
gets done and he's looking at me and I
look at him I go I go bro
what do you do in filming when there's a
freaking gun fight going on and he looks
at me and he goes
I was Winchester sir which means he was
out of ammo so he had already dumped
like a he dumped a thousand rounds or
probably 800 to a thousand rounds of
ammunition didn't have any ammo left and
so he's like well I might as well let's
make some videos but yeah I mean it it's
when I got home
I remember I was talking to some of the
Vietnam seals
and
I went and talked this one Vietnam sale
it was a machine gun or Vietnam
and you know I said I said you know how
many like how many engagements did you
get in
and he said oh you know we did whatever
it was he said you know we did 82
operations and we got seven gunfights
I said how many times did you use all
your ammunition he's never
and here it was I mean there was all
machine Gunners would run out of ammo on
a not a fairly regular but definitely
ran out of ammo because that's the that
was the scenario that was the situation
on the ground
and that's why he would take less water
he always took just what he hoped he
could you know need but and he would
substitute the water for animal yeah and
he'd be carrying radio sometimes too
yeah
[Music]
and he has a sense of humor oh yeah it's
the Moolah I can't believe you haven't
seen that video oh it's freaking classic
uh
meanwhile while that's going on back to
the book Hey Dad it's Mike Michael spoke
happily into a satellite phone he just
returned from an office after showering
and changing his Geary dialed home to
check in Mikey how you doing I'm doing
good Dad we're still training Iraqi
forces I'm pretty bored here yeah what's
new at home
Michael's careful not to detail the true
nature of the work they conducted on a
daily basis he didn't want his parents
to worry he preferred to keep the amount
of danger they face to himself
as George and Michael discussed his gear
and weapon Sally walked over to George
she was eager to hear Michael's voice
she had barely spoken to him since he
left because every time he called she
made sure her children and husband had
ample time with Michael on the phone
first she was also busy finishing up a
master's degree in counseling marriage
and family therapy so any amount of time
she had to speak with Michael she
treasured Michael never discussed any of
his combat operations with her she knew
he wanted to protect her from worrying
but she also knew better she had walked
past the hallway when her sons were on
their computer looking at photos of
Michael patrolling through the streets
and she instantly knew he was facing
grave enemy day in and day out
she couldn't be there but she could pray
and that's what she did
she prayed the rosary a collection of
prayers based on the Life of Christ and
honoring his Blessed Mother whom War
Fighters have credited assisting them in
Epic Battles throughout history
Sally wasn't seeking anything Grand with
her prayers she simply requested
protection for her son as she prayed it
every single day
is now Sally's turn to speak to Michael
and she held the phone tightly to her
ear so she could hear her son clearly
how are you Mike I miss you did you
receive the care packages we sent to you
we really enjoyed making them for you
and your teammates they were great mom
thank you even the package full of
female toiletries you and your friends
threw in there yeah these she had these
women volunteers and uh they did other
charity work and they sent stuff and so
nobody knows how that got in there but
Mike says you guys had kind of a crazy
look when they opened that one up like
are women coming
[Music]
yeah the the so my wife is at home she
got three kids they're like how old were
they they were like maybe seven
five and three or something like this
they're maybe you know six four and two
or something like this so she doesn't
have time to do all this stuff so
finally I get you know everyone's
getting a chiropractic and all this nice
stuff I'm not getting anything find me
like two months of deployment I get a
package and I still harass my wife about
this I like honey roasted peanuts right
and so she sent me a planners thing of
honey roasted peanuts but it was opened
and the tape shut open it was happy and
my freaking kids got into it it was tape
shot that's what I got I'm like thanks
darling
but I didn't ever get women's toiletries
yeah no one figured out where those came
from but uh they they got a lot of
women's magazines too from uh people
because so I would contact anybody that
would send things we sent staff and uh
people with volunteers and stuff and I
you know it was just crazy guys would
risk their life to go out and get those
packages you know hey woman toilet just
what we need uh
uh
he says I'm gonna go head to bed now I
want to say hello to you guys Mike's
voice began to drift off the day's
operation to begun to hit him like a
wall his body was now just registering
need for Sleep of course take care of
yourself we're all okay here Michael
stay focused so you can come home safe
Sally said those words became her
parting words every time she spoke to
him stay focused
so you can come home safe
we would uh lie in bed just kind of
looking at the ceiling and
foreign we all know that he's just not
kicking back you know it's kind of a
charade here you know but uh
we were pretty aware of what was how bad
ramadi was but we knew he didn't really
want to get into it so we kept the
conversation pretty light now when Mark
got killed did you guys did you guys
become aware when Mark got killed they
went to the funeral
and that's where uh Sally met uh met
Debbie Debbie uh
but uh also uh
I put you know I keep thinking K uh oh
oh from the book yeah makawi makawi got
it Cowie comes up to her in his crutches
and says Michael saved my life Michael
saved my life and
it's when Sal was thinking well how
could you save your life if he's just
marching people around and then he told
uh her the story and that's why
was like yeah
we know a little bit better than that
but uh and of course we had a
conversation I remind them we don't we
don't really need Heroes just do a good
job
and uh
he says Don't worry
um
if
I remember him saying uh we talked about
the staff about Lee staff and everything
and those guys took it pretty hard
and he and I said we're going to be
careful and he goes don't worry he says
if I go here I will be the one that
decides I still remember that
especially when he he didn't have to we
could have gotten out of that he decided
just always sticks in my head
a conversation
yeah I I know that uh I mean my wife had
no idea of what was going on
um at all and but then no because she
didn't even give you a full can that's
true I'd say she has no clue but you
know even Cowie got Cowie got wounded
but you know she just I think she just
thought it was anomaly and like I said I
mean she had uh she had a you know she
had three kids going on freaking young
kids and everything but uh I think
everybody when Mark got killed it was
like oh wake up yeah yeah and and um
yet I was looking through my emails a
while ago which is crazy to look through
emails and I have like all the emails I
was reading emails that I sent my wife
and you know it's like oh uh what is it
July
29th you know
um then July
1st or so July 31st and then
August 2nd that's the day Mark died and
there's you know my you know I sent an
email August 3rd like hey hope
everything's okay you know something
like this but still nothing
um and I think that was everybody you
know kind of like what Mikey was doing
so you just don't want people to worry
but then that was just uh no way to hide
that you know
what we saw Cowie again uh we invited
some of the seals for Thanksgiving
and we still didn't know the whole story
and then Thanksgiving
he says so can I can I talk to you and
they went into another room and he says
let me tell you what I saw
and then he pulls up his shirt and he
has that huge tattoo that was monster I
swear this is what I saw
so it was like
you know yeah yeah so Cowie who is uh
wasn't asking a Bruiser and was it was
just a freaking awesome guy
that's the the opening story is Mikey
dragging him out of the out of the
street
and
he ended up getting a tattoo of of Mikey
with these angels wings
it's Cali was telling the story the
other day and one thing I he he was
saying it was like he was about to say
something like he or maybe he was like
Hey I need and as soon as he was saying
I need help like he felt Mikey's hand
like grab his gear and start pulling him
he's like that's Johnny on the spot
right there yeah
yeah I'm I'm not that I'm not real
religious but things like this just hit
me and sometimes like
I don't know I don't have explanations
for some of these things
uh I think the older you get you start
to see more things there's just uh can't
really explain
but uh
it was the 15th of August the uh the
Iraqi Army along with the US Army would
be conducting clearance of another
portion of the malab district the houses
were tightly packed and clearance would
likely be slow the seals came prepared
and we're all set with cardboard shade
water and a ton of extra ammunition the
men didn't know it but they would soon
have no need for the shade as the call
to prayer ended Michael scanned the
surrounding area with his Periscope he
glanced over to see his teammates to the
right each with their own as well he
smiled and continued to scan it had
worked out so well for Michael that a
bunch of guys had had them sent out this
is Michael ended up getting his like
combat periscopes which ended up being
awesome yeah I remember Sarah was
sending that out and she's looking at me
like
playing games over there yeah imagine
how nice it is when you don't have to
poke your head up over a wall yeah
uh nothing to see here guys just the
Iraqi Army and dudes getting unloaded
Michael called then the loudspeakers
crackled on that's weird thought Michael
it seemed as though the prayers were
going to start again a voice came over
the loudspeakers but it sounded
different this time it was not the usual
singing it was speaking and the words
were different what is that are they
praying again that doesn't sound like
prayer Chief Orton said I know it's not
the same Michael responded The
Interpreter burst through the couple
adore and onto the roof it's directions
they're being direct directed he blurted
what who asked Chief Horton the speakers
the enemy Fighters are being directed on
where to go The Interpreter applied
oh well
oh well JP Doug Mike do you
have a shot to take out those speakers
chief called Chief Horton but the
snipers had already been trying to work
a solution no joy Chief was the response
Mikey I hope you brought a lot of ammo
shit's probably gonna get real stupid
real quick Chief Horton said
always Mikey replied
was that uh was that the 12 hour
uh ah
yeah yeah that one what ends up
happening com's chatter but mostly was
not pertinent to Michael mostly was
information flow from different units
leaders back to to the Joint Operation
Center where the operation is being
monitored Michael's concern was keeping
the enemy pinned and if one of them was
brave enough to try and move out in the
open dropping into his tracks the
clearance was ongoing but the insurgents
currently attacking the seal position
were Relentless and I fast forwarded to
this they just basically got like an
all-out assault this was not ideal but
also meant that they were not trying to
advance towards the OverWatch position
had been hours and neither side could
get the upper hand Michael moved from
position to position firing at multiple
enemy locations it looked as though this
fight was not going to be over anytime
soon and he wasn't wrong the entire
engagement lasted 12 hours I mean
imagine
people have never served
12 hours
I mean it's the way these guys stay
together and then the next day they go
up and do it again it's the people I
just don't it's just on it's just
remarkable what these guys do yeah you
know what uh a lot of times you know
people talk about basic SEAL training
and they talk about buds oh buds them's
hard and I look it is hard it's hard as
hell and it's a nightmare for guys to
try and get through
but what you just talked about and what
I usually try and explain to people is
oh you
saw an army guy get killed
you were in a firefight yesterday you
had round snap by your head you had like
all these things happen I mean on some
of these engagements
uh their JP dragged a marine out of the
street
I forget the number but the Marine got
shot another Marine got shot and Iraqi
got shot
a seal got shot through his backpack
through his uh water bladder his camel
back on his so I was like in one
little engagement five people got shot
and what do you do the next day you go
out again yeah and then the next day you
go out again so yeah the look Buzz is
hard I get it but this stuff right here
and look it's not just seals the Marines
are going out every day the Army's going
out every day and
everyone's taking those risks and that's
why the bond was so tight with the Army
and the Marine Corps in ramadi because
everyone was doing everything we could
to protect each other
and that's why that Bond was and is so
strong yeah
yeah I read some of uh
Michael's emails
uh and I was his friends in the states
crying that uh his girlfriend the
girlfriend doesn't love him anymore or
or her boyfriend laughed and they're
having a tough time in college and I'm
and Mike writes back you know encouraged
them and the whole deal and I'm thinking
really yeah they're having a tough time
yeah it's uh
it
it definitely is and that's what I love
about this book is you start to realize
the I mean this is what the daily life
is like
um captured it really really well and
that's I think that's important for
people to read these type of books
uh I can get a taste and these these
stories as you said they're from uh the
guys that were there these stories are
real and uh I think it would give the
rest of the country just kind of a
fingernail sketch of what these guys go
through and also if you have you know a
teenage children they can see that uh
guys like Michael they're just like them
they they have problems when they're
kids and they deal with bullies and it's
that determination that strength that
you build up in your life that prepares
you for the world
yeah and uh you know the fact that the
first time Mikey went to buds he quit
yeah and you you know who else did Mark
Lee Mark Lee the first time he went to
Buds
and I always uh you know occasionally
I'll talk to someone that's that had
been to Buds and quit and I usually tell
them if they seem like they're a good
person I'll say if they're if they say
they want to go back and I'll say hey
you're at a Mikey monster and they say
you want to go Mikey monster quit the
first time he went and now I'm going to
be able to tell him but when you get
defeated it's what you do what's what's
the quote I gotta learn
it's how you come back from the feet
come back from defeat so that's what I'm
talking about what's the man we're gonna
add that in there whatever it is it's
the way you come back it's always wake
up because we've all had losses and for
me when I have a bad loss uh it just
burns them Burns it's there forever you
sometimes you forget about those easy
wins but you remember those losses and
usually hopefully you'll walk away with
a lesson
and uh Michael just when that happened I
just it didn't surprise me at all he was
coming back he will win yeah
so pushing a little bit further into
deployment
we're getting towards the end of
deployment Michael gripped the phone
close to his mouth hey Dad we're just
about done here I volunteered to stay
for a few more operations so one of the
guys could leave early his wife is
having a baby soon it won't be long I
expect to be finished up in about a week
I'll also be helping do to do turnover
with the incoming team then I'm heading
out my stuff is packed and ready to go
that's great news Mikey your mom and I
can't wait to see you we're going to
celebrate and have a big party when you
get back stateside George felt a great
relief to learn that Mikey was so close
to coming home and almost silly for
having thought that he may not see his
son again
take care of yourself
and we'll see you soon
and that's something you told me uh
oh a little while ago was that Mikey was
always
telling you about who's married and
checking in on who has kids and that was
a big concern it is was he knew who had
kids who was married and he he would
tell me I worry about these guys he goes
I don't want to be the guy that lost one
of these uh one of these guys who has
children because he believed fathers
mothers is you know a two-person deal
and he's always loved kids and he just
would be so bothered knowing that on his
watch somebody lost the father and it he
would talk about I mean how many people
really want to find out who's got kids
in there but he he would want to know
and he would keep it in the back of his
mind
so I know it always concerned him
because he just didn't want to lose a
father
foreign
there was the 28th of September and the
first of the 506 had one last request
operation Kentucky jumper the seals
would be providing OverWatch for combat
Outpost Eagle's Nest while the external
wall of the combat Outpost was being
reinforced in addition the first the 506
would be conducting a clearance in the
same area which the seals would cover as
well
the insert would take place at night the
two elements would leave cop Eagle's
Nest and set up mutually supporting
rooftop OverWatch positions in two
prominent houses much like they have
been doing for the entire deployment
the men and conducted this type of
operation many times and at this point
it seemed like this one would be much
the same
so they push in they do this OverWatch
around 11 A.M the Army moved out of the
area having finished operations for the
day the seal OverWatch positions
remained in place and would extract
under the cover of Darkness later that
night
other than the first the 506 doing
clearance Ops and us being in the area
providing OverWatch it was kind of a
somber day Doug said referring to how
the day was going in comparison to other
similar operations they had completed
based on most of the previous operations
the likelihood of the firefight was low
of another firefight was low the
temperature was reaching 115 degrees and
they would stay there until late into
the afternoon and only begin to cool
when the sun dip below the horizon
as the morning turned into day and then
early afternoon Michael Doug and Mike S
talked of heading home
and what was next for each of them there
was a sense of excitement we were proud
of what we did we are proud of our
relationships we had built with the Army
in the Marine Corps recalls Mike cirelli
the men talked of their families Doug
would be headed back to Georgia to see
his three sons Mike S was ready to get
back to his two-year-old little girl
Michael listened as the guy spoke of
heading home he was ready as well sniper
School heading into his next platoon
snowboarding trips and driving up the
coast to see his family in Garden Grove
Doug recalls how cool and relaxed
Michael was
he just had a real calming sense to him
you could tell instantly what a great
person and Warrior he was to this point
it was the most one-on-one time Doug had
spent with Michael
as the date continued on the intense
heat had begun to wear on the men the
shade material helped but not but the
heat radiated from surfaces all around
them not even the light Breeze brought
reprieve the air was stifling dry and
filled with dust
the lack of activity and the heat
induced lethargy
degrading the men's awareness boom
an explosion rocked the rooftop Michael
ran back over to the position between
Mike S and Doug
what was that RPG asked Doug sure seemed
like it Mike S replied the anger on
Michael's face was apparent as he
searched for the Insurgent responsible
for the attack Mike S moved out of his
loophole and called the other element we
just took an RPG searching for the
shooter now what have you guys got
Doug rolled into the open spot
as it had a better field of view than
his loophole Michael sat on the chair
between the two with his Mark 48 resting
on the wall of the rooftop Mike S
continued updating the other element
while Michael Doug and Benny scanned the
area they saw nothing no enemy movement
suddenly an object just barely cleared
the lip of the wall and hit Michael in
the chest it bounced off and rolled to
the ground directly in front of him
Mike S looked over at what had just
landed next to the group then up at
Michael Michael stood so quickly and
with such force that the chair he was
sitting on sailed across the rooftop and
impacted the opposite wall
Michael looked at Mike S and yelled
grenade
Mike S watched in disbelief as Michael
the only one of them who had an out to
escape the blast instead
lunged forward
dropping directly onto the grenade
Seth's element had heard and seen the
two blasts from their OverWatch position
and were already moving when the call
for help came in the men urgently picked
up the pace when they heard the amount
of enemy automatic weapons fire that
their friends were receiving they broke
out from the main house the main
entrance and headed west initially it
was all quiet at their position but
within 15 seconds of hitting the street
all hell broke loose enemy rounds
snapped and skipped around them they
moved from cover to cover returning fire
as they closed the distance to the other
OverWatch position
they were only two blocks away but to
the wounded seals it seemed like it took
forever for the other element to arrive
hold on Mikey hold on
Mike S said as he and Doug continued to
assess and Aid Michael suddenly a seal
from the other element burst onto the
roof and headed over to Doug Mike S and
Michael
he was followed by Seth and the other
seals one of the strongest seals grabbed
Michael and hoisted him onto his back
Seth grabbed Doug
and the others took Mike S
they could hear the 25 millimeter Auto
Cannons of the Bradley Fighting Vehicles
begin to fire effectively suppressing
the enemy
and providing cover for the seals to
load their wounded
Mike S directed the group as they move
down the stairs and into the alley to
the waiting Bradley's Doug Mike S and
Michael were loaded onto the boat into
the back along with one of the seals
from the other element
he stayed to continue to Aid Michael
while the Bradleys extracted them and
headed back to Camp Corregidor
when the wounded seals arrived
they saw the men from the first the 506
lined up waiting to support whatever
they could another Testament to the bomb
that the two units shared
Doug Mike gas and Michael were loaded
onto stretchers and brought into the Aid
Station
on the camp
Doug and Mike S were given shots of
morphine for the first time since the
grenade explosion they finally had
reprieved from the physical piercing
pain
the reprieve however were short-lived
the atmosphere in the room shifted the
mood had darkened and the two men could
feel it
then they overheard the nurse say it
Michael was gone
in that sobering moment they became
aware of what Michael had given them
he'd freely exchanged his life for
theirs
it was September 29th
the feast day of Saint Michael the Arte
art the archangel
the protector and guide of War Fighters
since time immemorial
and whom Michael had been named
25 years earlier
it was a bad day for the family
member Jim called me you could hear him
crying
dad is bad
it's bad
I said what's bad he says
Michael Michael died
Marty
please get a hold of Joe
I tried to call Joe and I finally got a
hold of him he was uh playing football
and
North Dakota
and uh
I couldn't even tell him finally got a
hold of him I couldn't even tell him I
couldn't even talk
to call your brother
until I guess when Sal saw him at the
door the Navy she just knew
bad day
I just uh because we get you had that
call that says I'm coming home
so now it's like all your planning is
what we're going to do when we get
together
uh
didn't happen
I
well so I'd been tracking the operation
I was in the Tactical operations center
and and it was troops in contact which
was like
like I said this was like a almost daily
occurrence that guys would be in there
and then
you know you got what you hear wounded
and all of a sudden that's not common
and
um the kazovaks get called and I can
hear some of the radio calls and I I end
up redirecting the kazavac
to their location
and and finally it was actually Colonel
Clark God bless him
he he called me
and um
yeah he told me uh
he told me uh cirelli and Doug he said
they were
they were wounded but they're gonna be
all right he said Benny was gonna be
okay he said that surely and and Doug
were gonna be for you know getting flown
out
and he's and he said Mike you weren't
gonna make it
and um
I mean we sent guys to escort Mikey home
and
I mean we still had to finish deployment
we decided to turn over with the next
guys
and and thankfully Andrew Paul
he's the guy that that had come home
early yeah Mike relieved them so he
could have the his wife could have the
baby
and so he knew I mean obviously he was
Mikey's you know assistant platoon
Commander with Seth and and and
thankfully he was home
so that he could be there but oh I mean
as soon I talked to Seth Seth and Seth
had to go back out into town
by the way they got back and Seth had to
go back
into the city because they left their
Iraqis there they left a bunch of gear
there and so Seth had to go back out
gather up their Iraqis gather up all
their gear come back and then he called
me in heat
immediately he he knew
um he said hey Mikey jumped on that
Mikey jumped on a grenade
and a few hours later
I talked to uh Mike and Doug and they're
in Germany
and they're like
hey he saved us
that's the only reason we're here
and
um talked to Seth and Seth was like
drafting up the Medal of Honor and I was
like do it
[Music]
and I remember I did
when Seth came to visit the house I
didn't want to see him it was like I've
had it with you guys I don't want to see
it
Seth is hard to say no to him because
you can see the sincerity on his face
downtown
you know the family
we just worked it out but
we can cry at any moment we think of
Mike that's um
it's the way it is I I know uh
and man Sarah your daughter what a what
a just awesome woman very strong very
strong
and
I remember her and I don't know she said
it to me but I think I remember her
seeing it later people were you know you
guys were getting interviewed she was
getting interviewed and
she was basically someone said you know
you are you surprised that this happened
and she said no anybody that knew Mike
he's not surprised by this
um
yeah
uh
when at what point did you hear about
the Medal of Honor
uh what happened was uh
some guy from the newspaper called us
about it and I didn't know what he was
talking about and we hadn't gotten so
many calls all kinds of things we had
hate calls we had uh newspapers uh
interviews most of the stuff we said no
and uh we just want to be left alone in
fact we were so used to getting bad
calls uh I remember the president uh who
was trying to call us
because this is when they decided to
award him
um
of the medal and uh
Sarah kept trying to tell me which would
you pick up the phone
and I was thinking this is I go what's
this guy keeps bothering me it's just
the same number I don't know what this
wants and then she was dead
would you just pick up the phone you
know so that's when we knew it was real
because you hear people everyone is
talking with you know to do this and
that but I mean it's nice but
it's not your son you know
it's uh it our family appreciated it but
you know that hole is still there I
think anyone who's Lost the Child I
don't care if it's in the hospital an
accident there's a hole and we're in a
real sad family and me and Debbie Lee
were talking about it it's just it's
just there and it just hits you every
once you out
hearing kids playing the playground or
something like that it just hits you
it's
just don't get over it but uh we're
treated very very nicely
surprising because I was in the Marines
and
the Seal family
is totally different and I was kind of
shocked
I was like almost two so I go okay well
leave us alone you know but I was really
taken back by
um you know these guys coming over and
checking on the family and it was a good
thing
at what point did you hear about the
ship
I was about
I remember Dr winter talked about a ship
and see we don't know anything about the
Navy uh we're not into the ceremony
stuff and it was like yeah okay whatever
uh
you know uh really think about it it was
just in passing we thought and then a
while later maybe uh
six months later uh we get this thing
where they're going to name a ship after
Michael
we had no no idea it was going to be
like 10 years
I mean it was just
incredible and it was like fly-haired
fly there and
that's why my kids we're not going any
place we didn't realize it was going to
turn into a job and uh it was everything
was nice and uh but it's not something
we really wanted
we were real happy to just go back to a
simple nobody knows this and so it was
it was busy for the first couple years
and finally it you know it disappeared
and it was okay but
um
I would think leave it to Mikey
he's still got something going on and
even this book people will talk to me uh
we'd have a writer sitting on our porch
wanting to write a book and what's the
Hat a dozen of them we passed on all of
them
and then just uh when one of the sailors
did a book on Michael and gave it to a
submissive at the cemetery
and that's when I started thinking my
grandchildren should have a book because
they should see what it's like
um you know they got to understand that
Michael Uncle Michael went through some
of the same things they went through you
know it just doesn't happen you've got
to have
you know you've got to be able to figure
things out you have to be strong enough
because when you're a kid you're bullied
or you're you know you're not sure of
yourself the world is is really scary
for them and I thought it would be good
that they could see their uncle had the
same kind of problems and he got through
it and they can get through it too
so and I would hope anybody who would
read this the same thing you know a
young man or reading this uh realizes
he's he's got a long ways to go in his
life and he can pull himself together
some guys I hired a lot of young people
in my time and some of them they just
never got that message
now they're in their 30s and 40s and
they're still children yeah so um yeah
it's weird too I I got to admit from my
perspective when you talk about Mikey
like as a boy
by the time he was in the teams which is
when I met him yeah she was no boy no
and and and then I was telling you this
before we started recording like he was
getting big right yeah so he cut the
sleeves off all the shirts everybody
started calling him sleeves because he
was just like getting jacked but I mean
he was
you know even even we said Kevin lace
Kevin lace is a really big guy
but Mikey was also big so it's
interesting when you put it all together
and like you say the Arc of the book
the Mikey I knew was just a badass right
and he might have been a new guy and he
might have been you know like young for
the SEAL Teams but he was a badass so to
connect that to this guy who you know
had asthma and got bullied and like like
while I knew Mike Mike was not getting
bullied by anybody
so he had uh overcome all that and and
like you said
um
risen up and at the same time that he
had that quality
like there's literally no one else that
you would rather have to watch your back
yeah
no he was if if he said I've got it he
meant it you know if if he says you're
my friend you could you could take it to
the bank he will do everything uh that
he can if you if you have a problem and
I remember Gabe talking about how close
they were Gabe was uh was Greek and
Michael being a Lebanese they would he
would call him his Lebanese brother no
no he called his Mediterranean brother
I'm gonna go out and choke on some
olives or something I don't know
uh
you know this the the stuff with the
ship
um
I mean it was it was I see I got to look
at it from afar right I wasn't all mixed
up in it like you guys were flying all
the time yeah uh you guys the Keel this
is from the book The Keel Lang is the
first of three ceremonies in the life of
a ship symbolizing the ship's transition
from a mere concept to a product that
will one day become a U.S warship Navy
tradition celebrated special Keel laying
ceremony for hundreds of years yeah
and so it talks about the fact that you
guys went to Bath Iron Works up in Maine
and and welded your initials onto this
like piece that goes in there that's
sort of the that's sort of the initial
there's just so much tradition yeah that
the Navy has
yeah and it was yeah we would do those
things and then Sal welded something in
uh uh on the bridge someplace you know
and it's like
yeah and they somehow got wood this guy
Captain Smith who's a great guy after
Kevin Scott Smith who like took this
with the utmost seriousness of course
because he's the first commanding
officer of this ship and he got they got
wood from the USS Constitution it was
like crazy how do you do that uh you
have this here each Naval warship has
its own Creston motto and Captain Smith
who's the first commanding officer took
meticulous efforts to honor the ship's
namesake with each one for the crest he
was given parameters of Simply using a
shield
the rest was up to him he knew exactly
what to do in order to make sure the
ship honored its names it's the ship and
namesake perfectly
there were a handful of people family
teammates and Friends he would need to
talk to he was introduced to Steve
Gilmore retired surface Naval surface
Warfare he's the best uh he he is
he's just on your side oh he's he's a
hundred percent uh he helped me I'm very
good friends with him and he helped me
with everything I ever need help with
and look I caused all kinds of trouble
for that poor guy I was constantly
constantly causative he would bail me
out of all kinds of things so thank you
Mr Steve Gilmore
uh
but he was able to connect Captain Smith
with a bunch of different people Captain
Smith sat down for hours with each group
learned as much as he could in order to
create something remarkable that would
Inspire his future crew members
they would collectively come up with the
the connected with it with a uh
something that connected the family with
the Navy as well as the ship's unique
components and so this is for the motto
of the ship became I will defend
which carries a three-fold meeting every
military member takes an oath to support
and defend the Constitution another
prominental military ethos says I will
defend the defenseless
and the Saint Michael prayer calls upon
the mighty Angelic Soldier to defend Us
in battle
have you been in have you been in the
ship I have I when I talked to Scott I
was like uh we wanted something for the
seals
not to be forgotten and uh that's why if
you walk in you'll see the pictures of
those other seals and uh I was important
to us that the those seals are forgotten
because sometimes
Congressional Medal of Honor people
forget about these people well pain is
the same and we want to remember them on
that ship so he did a good job for us no
they did a beautiful job the ship was
the ship was awesome and they ended up
with the the there's a flintlock pistol
which came from the Trident thing which
is awesome there's a there's a Roman
numeral three which is like legit for
team three Scott did his homework yeah
he definitely um
definitely did an awesome job with all
that and eventually uh
the ship gets christened
and and
[Applause]
that was just awesome
um
christening took place
that was up in bath as well up in Maine
that was when uh Sally broke the yeah
that was fun for her she was so afraid I
just want to make sure I hit it hard
enough I go put my face right there
I'm sure you'll be able to muster
hitting that thing
uh and then finally you get the actual
ships commissioning yeah and this is
when the ship becomes a U.S Navy ship
but it says here major holiday
was announced and approached the podium
to give the invocation he had flown in
all the way from Korea for the special
event
Upon finishing his opening prayer the
other speakers approached the podium one
after the other they rendered their
special remarks and honored the family
of the ship's namesake as well as the
impressive ship itself then Major
General Ron Clark
who was formerly a lieutenant colonel
who's now a major general this is how
long it's been here who led the first to
506 red curry he Battalion during the
Battle of vermati walked commandingly
over to the podium
we few we happy few we Band of Brothers
[Music]
for he today that shares that sheds his
blood with me shall be my brother
The Bravery and sacrifice of these
Warriors is the highest form of service
to our nation at a time when less than
one percent of American citizens will
ever Don the cloth of our nation in her
defense these men and women endured
hardship danger and personal sacrifice
every day to protect our country and our
way of life let me be very clear
our Band of Brothers was brought
together through our fight against a
tough and violent enemy
in fact we refer to Seal Team 3 as army
seals
it was the fight that brought us
together but really what defined our
task force was one word
love
a brotherly love that Warriors in arms
share in battle defined by selfless
commitment to a mission and selfless
commitment unfailing to one another
there is no greater human emotion than
the feeling to belong
to a team to a unit to a Brotherhood to
a family
my association with these Warriors has
been the most meaningful professional
relationships of my life
then you anybody who served understands
that I mean there are guys that I met in
the service that uh I love them as much
as my own Brothers
and the kind of situation in ramadi
that's even deeper
yeah Debbie Lee will will explain that
you know Mark would tell her
these oh these guys are my brothers and
she'd say well what do you mean like you
have a brother you know it's not the
same and and then when Mark died and she
met all of us she realized oh
you are brothers yeah you put the seal
squeeze on her too
finally the ship's sponsor and soul
woman on stage
walk to the podium she smiled her
humbled demeanor evidence Hall in
attendance she began by sharing her
heartfelt gratitude to all who were with
them to honor her son she continued
thanking the men and women of the
military whom she regarded as the best
in the world
finally without further Ado she gave an
order that the crew had been eagerly
awaiting to hear officers and crew of
the USS Michael monsor man our ship and
bring her to life
that was a good day that was awesome and
that
we weren't the ship's crew but they had
task unit Bruiser was the guys that ran
up yeah and manned the ship yeah
um luckily we didn't have to drive
anywhere with it or anything none of us
know how to do any of that but but man
it was just awesome to see that and and
yeah you hustled pretty good I saw you
guys out there and they're going when
was the last time those guys ran well so
uh you know the guys before yeah
they're like hey Jocko like don't run
too fast because like some guys
right so of course I'm all fired up with
adrenaline and all all hyped and I guess
I went a little quicker than I showed up
but you know wore some of the guys out
uh and just to close this out
um father holiday steps up to the podium
let us pray heavenly father bless and
approve this newly commissioned vessel
the USS Michael Monsour and its crew
send your Holy Angels as custodians and
guides
May Michael and the Archangel ever
defend it in battle be its protector
against all enemies and ravages of foul
weather May this vessel and crew always
know the Friendship of the creatures of
the deep the camaraderie of the Winds
and the enmity of the tides and may the
USS Michael Monsour ever know the
unified patronage of the citizens of
Heaven the creatures of Earth
and every Mission it undertakes to
restore peace ensure freedom
and enact justice for all
I've met so many really wonderful people
uh over this and father holiday was was
one uh he also did a mass and baptized
Joseph's son on that ship nice yeah
so there's just a lot of really really
great people and um
as far as that Sal and I were just it
was some good times Well now is that is
that Joseph's on Mikey yeah
yeah it is the weirdest thing right so
as you know I wrote this book Mikey and
the dragons right and it's obviously
it's the Mikey's named after Mikey and
my friend John bozak's the artist
and uh I'm like hey you know here's the
story and so he sends me the first
pictures and they're black and white so
I don't really think much of it
and then first color one comes
and in the book you've got Mikey with
blonde hair and I'm like hey man you
know like Mikey's freaking Lebanese bro
he's black here
and but then when you look at the book
and he's like talking me through it you
look at the book like even the cover
like it's all black and got this blonde
head kid makes a kid stand out and I'm
like yeah
all right well hey we're gonna bleach
out Mikey a little bit close enough but
then I meet Little Mikey yeah and sure
enough yeah
uh I think I told you I was complaining
to Joe I says Joe you got three little
girls and you got Mikey and they're all
toe heads I said you couldn't have given
me one brown kid with a big nose
seriously
[Music]
oh oh man um
but I mean it is awesome seeing that
ship and and with this book that you
just wrote with Rose and Rose did a
fantastic job you know she's married to
a seal so she captured a lot of stuff
put up with a lot of stuff yeah I'm sure
it's pretty tough related yeah just
trying to get stories out of guys
everyone's on all different schedules no
she did a great job and like and because
she's married to a seal I think she
captured it in a way that um a normal
author wouldn't have been able to yeah
when we talked um
she pestered me for two years
and Steve would go I don't know I think
she's pretty good
anyway uh we we talked it was like
um
I said we don't we want like real
stories because she gave sinian samples
of of uh other of authors and they wrote
about the glory of war and all that and
I said I want to vomit I said that is
not what we're looking for we want real
stuff and so uh what was good about the
seals is she couldn't call them they
wouldn't give her the time of day
I would call them and tell them what I'd
like to do and we had a lot of stories
but a lot of the guys they didn't want
to share those stories it was personal
and so I respect that but some of the
guys uh after a couple of calls they
would open up uh to uh to Rose and uh I
felt like as they opened up they
actually felt good about it and it kind
of like let some let out a little bit of
some of that pressure what happened over
there and I was surprised how many said
it was okay if they used uh you know
their name so that's when I started
thinking well then they probably feel
pretty good about it and it's these are
all true stories so
I I think it's uh it's a book that is
worth reading no it's uh that's 100
worth reading and
it's a way for Mikey's Legacy to you
know to carry on carry on the ship and
it's great when you meet the ship and
the ship's crew there they all know the
story they're all fired up I mean they
do an awesome thing and and it's written
about in the book as well as you know
when you pull into San Diego Harbor
off to your left hand side is rosecrants
where Mikey's buried and you know
actually Mark's buried there and set
Stones buried there
but when you pull in they they man the
rails and they give the the ship salute
you know to Mikey which is just awesome
so you get the Legacy carrying on with
the crew with the ship in this book um
and in the the young you know the young
seals today
they're this is what they're raised on
they're raised on this is what a this is
this is the ideal seal this is a guy
that works hard that's never going to
give up and that's going to take care of
his brothers and that's you know that's
Mikey well you have those I think you
have marks in there and and Mike he's uh
when the seals come in they see those
displays yeah and I I actually think
it's important so people don't forget
um no matter who it is there are guys
that really uh they believed in what
they did and these young sales should
know that um it's passed on to them
well
thank you
so much for writing this book uh thanks
to rose as well thanks for coming down
here uh Hey Echo you got any questions
no sir no sir you just woke him up
[Music]
uh
anybody that's listening the books
available will have it on our website
but you can get it on Amazon you can get
it wherever books are sold just get it I
mean give it to give it to everybody
that you know give it to like how you
mentioned teenagers for sure
because I think they can understand
even you know it's not like uh it's not
like this Pro thing where they're gonna
kid or parents are scared their kids are
going to run out and join the military
it's the journey that he took and what
he overcame and these kids who are
feeling you know insecure they got to
know that there's other guys out there
just like them and they did it and they
can these kids can also get through it
and it's important and that's why I did
it for my grandkids and I think I told
you my my granddaughter uh she first
weekend
um in boot camp and she I gave her one
of these books uh for the trip and she
read it and she said
when I read the story because I hate
boot camp so much and she goes
but I realized you know life is tough
and there's it's a journey and we have
to go through these things and Mike was
my inspiration she goes we had to run a
mile and a half and I'd never run faster
and she goes I just she says thanks
Grandpa for writing the book it's
important So eventually all the kids
will get one and a couple of words I
want to take out but I don't know
it's a true story so what am I going to
do
it's surprisingly clean considering it's
about well yeah yeah
uh but but no it's awesome and uh any
any other closing thoughts I think that
gets us up to present date no I do want
to thank you for uh
for the respect for our family and
especially uh how much you helped out
Sally
uh she uh she really appreciated in the
time where she couldn't get to the into
the cemetery
she says to me she goes I hope I didn't
I didn't disturb him or anything I
thought he was on base and I go whoa is
he wearing them I think he was just
wearing t-shirts and his shorts and I
said I don't think that's the uh the
uniform of the day
uh no that wasn't the uniform of the day
I think you're on vacation or something
I don't know yeah I wasn't at work yeah
I got a college hey if uh Sally wants to
go and visit her son at Rosecrans she's
going to get in there yeah and she was
thrilled she was just so happy because
it's like hour and a half two hours try
and she didn't know that they closed up
you know at that time but I really want
to thank you because she was treated
very well with the seals and with you
and I also want to thank you for
attending her funeral
very nice
it was an honor to be there and it's a
an honor to help share this story of
Mikey and
thanks for joining us
um
thanks for you know the sacrifice of you
your whole family I mean that
thanks for uh
for raising a sun like Mikey
and for sharing them with us we won't
forget him
well we really appreciate the seal
community and like I said we appreciated
the way we were treated the respect from
you and this family was important
I just wanted to close that out because
who knows when I'm going to see you
again and I really appreciate it
this moment so thanks Jaco thank you
and with that George Mansour has left
the building
and
once again
life is a gift
and thanks for listening
we appreciate it
and if you want to support the podcast
but first of all get the book like I
said I read like little pieces of the
book the book has a bunch more in it
they did a great job
writing it so order the book
what is is it is it Christmas season yet
or yeah technically I think it's kind of
the beginning even if you're having a
lean Christmas yeah even if you're
having a lean Christmas just order the
book today and you can give it to
everybody that you know
so we'll just start with that uh
support this book please
if you want to further support the
podcast while you're supporting yourself
go and get some Jocko fuel from
jockoffuel.com
you can get drinks
energy drinks
you can get protein
you can get joint Warfare a bunch of
stuff that's going to help you
jockoffuel.com also you can get the
drinks at Wawa you can get
everything at Vitamin Shop the military
Commerce commissaries Hannaford's
Dash stores in Maryland wake Fern and
ShopRite Circle K in Florida HEB and
Tejas
Murphy's in the Southeast and Meyer in
the Midwest
so if you need
Jocko fuel go there and get it or
jacoville.com
it's true yeah George offline was asking
about like hey do you have anything for
joints and aches because I'm getting
older we do we do yeah if you go read
the reviews of joint Warfare it's legit
yeah
so yeah it's uh it's one of those things
where I mean you know when you're young
you know you don't pay attention to that
kind of stuff but if you maintain like
solid Health joint right you'll flow
right into uh old adulthood and be fine
trust me is that where you're at that's
where I'm at Old adult yeah that's super
cool too yeah honestly it's kind of a
double it's kind of a double attack yeah
yeah that's they pair together well as
we see so there you go jocklefuel.com
get it
also origin USA
hunt coming out yeah yeah I could you
feel that once George started talking
about
Factory and production I was like almost
gonna go down the path and also we could
be talking about made in America and
what it's like running production and
what it's like to you know build or make
clothing because that's what he was
doing running a factory yeah
so uh but we luckily I refrained from
going down the path
and talking about that uh but we are
making stuff in America originusa.com go
get some stuff there get hunt gear by
the way we're making as fast as we can
hey will look we know you bought it is
it for what is it still pre-order right
now no no no we're shipping it out as
fast as we can oh I have a high demand
yeah I have it but we've we're shipping
it out as fast as we can we're making as
fast as we can we appreciate the
patience uh we're working it that's what
we're doing
but hey jeans
get those Delta genes the Delta 68s
Delta 68s are just the deal kind of 100
now look if you live in Michigan you
live in Minnesota you might get the
factory genes which are a little heavier
because it's winter time you might be
feeling it yeah if you're in the
Southern America
or in a warm place in the world you're
going to want those Delta 68s all day
all day and you're probably training Jiu
Jitsu that's how it all started by the
way
the Jiu Jitsu geez you don't need to get
one that's made in a communist country
you get one that's made by free people
not slaves no that's originusa.com go
get it yep it's true also chocolate
store Jocko store
so we can get your shirts and hoodies
and hats and stuff rash guards on there
as well but yeah discipline equals
Freedom it's good you want to represent
it's a good place to get yourself that
thing that you're wearing right now is
that a yes to the Jocko store yep it's
called Lux it's called team discipline
team discipline yep you named it yep get
over their naming shirts now well they
all have names
okay actually you know what okay so you
know the shirt you're wearing right now
your uniform what what is that tear I
don't forget how the tears work in
uniforms three because I don't know if
there's such a thing as a tear or what
do you call there's like a the Jer the
dress oh yeah and then there's blues and
then the classes or something like that
okay yeah yeah well either way my
general uniform that's your uniform
right that's the shirt that shirt is
called Black Ops I actually knew that so
I guess I knew this yeah I knew this
shirt was called but there's always a
white one called Declassified oh and
then now there's a new one cleverness
that's a new one it's just like that but
instead of the dark gray it's red it's
called red team dang look at you can I
get a gray one
yeah you know what would that be called
uh yeah I don't we don't make currently
make the gray one but hey look I'll look
into it I know a guy and you know maybe
we'll uh we'll make that happen a gray
one huh
could be cool great great show it's
because they don't get dirty but they're
cool in the sun call it um gray area or
great operations isn't that a thing when
it's not right or wrong you know it's
like gray we could call it gray gray
area one of those things either way yes
Jacob we also have a shirt Locker these
designs are are interesting the last one
is called or this month is called the
heavies
that's a badass t-shirt by the way you
know
Jerry can't have those yeah it was good
okay
the Heavies is good yeah that little
section of that podcast yeah freaking
good section the Heavies are rolling in
yep but yeah that's a subscription
scenario you get a new shirt every month
people seem to like it so check that out
also there's it's called the shirt
Locker it's on Jocko store yep and
subscribe to the podcast And subscribe
to Jocko underground.com this is why
we're doing it because right now you see
some social media activities that are
going on right now there's mayhem out
there all right isn't there mayhem out
there
there's mayhem out there so we gotta
watch out for that and
well you just gotta watch out for that
so
that's where we have Taco on the ground
we got a YouTube
you can subscribe to that originusa has
some stuff on YouTube too check that one
out psychological warfare flip side
canvas Dakota Meyer
something to make some cool stuff to
hang on your wall books already
obviously defend Us in battle
just order that book
just get it
only cry for the living by Holly McKay
get that book and then I've written a
bunch of books too but whatever kids
books you know Mikey and the dragons
let's let's give that one some props
Mike and the dragons overcoming fear
obviously Mikey the character is named
after
Mike Monsour
about overcoming fear uh Echelon front
we have a leadership consultancy we
solve problems through leadership go to
ashlandfront.com for details next event
Orlando
April 3rd through the 5th that's the
next muster
April 3rd through the 5th 2023. it's
going to come quick that's the weird
thing and it's going to sell out quick
everything sells out we oversold the
last muster we oversold we had to like
move the instructor seating to the
behind the curtain type scenario yeah so
we won't make that mistake again but we
will sell out so there you go Orlando
April 3rd through the 5th 2023 and then
Dallas
is also in 2023.
we got the battlefield we got FTX we've
got all kinds of good stuff going on
echelonfront.com we also have online
training at extreme ownership Academy go
to extreme ownership.com we're covering
the stuff I was there I was on there
live today answering questions life was
on there live today answering questions
we have courses to take
so go to extreme ownership.com if you
want to learn how to live your life
better especially your interactions with
other humans and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their families gold star
families check out Mark Lee's mom
Ma Lee she's got a charity organization
and she will be coming on the podcast
very soon
and if you want to donate or get
involved with her her organization go to
America's Mighty Warriors dot org and
also don't forget about Micah Fink up
there in the the North country
with Heroes and horses.org helping
veterans find themselves while they get
a little bit lost out there in the
wilderness
and speaking of uh social media we're on
social media
on the gram on Twitter it's a new
Twitter these days nothing's changed
really have you noticed any change yet
besides the fact that you lost your
Twitter account yeah you got hacked I
got hacked and then they abused it they
took it over yeah they took it the
hackers took over my account to do a
bunch of spam stuff that's and then
Twitter shut it down because it was a
bot now but then luckily you said
forget it get it back you're old handled
so I registered again on my old handle
and I got it back so you're still at
Echo Charles still at Echo I wonder if
that's going to change because elon's
coming in eight dollars and this all
this stuff is going on so yeah we'll see
I heard about that people are freaking
out about all kinds of things the thing
is all the social media Facebook the
Graham Twitter you just gotta watch out
because the algorithm will grab you
that's what's gonna happen
and uh once again thanks to
thanks to George monsor for coming on
board and really
um the entire monster family who I've
been blessed to have gotten to know over
the past 15 years
um
just been amazing an honored to know
them and it's an honor to be here
and and share the story of Mikey uh
absolute
hero and example for all of us
so thank you to the entire Mansour
family
and
thanks to all the people from the
military in general the Army Navy Air
Force Marines as you could probably tell
we had an incredible relationship with
all of them
and we thank you for supporting us on
the battlefield
and in the past and now those that are
still active duty out there protecting
us today thank you and we also want to
thank our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all First Responders out
there you protect us here at home
and we thank you for it
and everyone else out there
on Mikey's gravestone
that Force Fort Rosecrans National
Cemetery
he gives some advice on there
it's the same thing that he told his dad
all those years before deployment
that no matter what happens
I have no regrets
so let's go try to live like Mikey did
work hard
if you get knocked down get back up
again and overcome
and of course
put others first
live your life
and leave no regrets
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko